When WestJet first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to WestJetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Horrible Sipulka.
1996年WestJet首航时，氛围有些不同。那时人们认为全身牛仔装是时尚巅峰，轮滑鞋随处可见，每三个女性中就有两个留着“瑞秋头”。虽然这些事物留在了90年代，但有一点从未改变，那就是当你登上WestJet航班时感受到的那种温馨。为WestJet自96年以来的飞行干杯。和我们一起穿越回过去，并真正与我们一起旅行，请访问westjet.com/30years。Horrible Sipulka。
Bloody moon. Claddy moon. Last hour. Special order number one Shrouted Brotherhood of Montgomery Division number 71 The great high giant commands you The dark and decimal hour will soon be Some live today
血月。克拉迪月。最后一小时。一号特别命令，蒙哥马利分部第71号蒙面兄弟会，伟大的高大巨人命令你们，黑暗与毁灭的时刻即将到来，有些人今天还活着
Tomorrow die Be ye ready The wetted sword The bullet red And the rights are ours dare not wear the holy garb of our mystic brotherhood save in quest of blood mark well our friends
明天就会死去，做好准备，湿透的剑，红色的子弹，权利属于我们，除非在追求鲜血的任务中，否则不敢穿上我们神秘兄弟会的圣袍，记住这一点，我们的朋友
let the guilty beware in the dark caves in the mountain recesses everywhere our brotherhood appears traders beware by order of the great grand SACLAPS. So that wasn't Jimmy Carter. That was a message that appeared on posters around Montgomery,
让罪人小心，在山洞的黑暗中，在山区的隐蔽处，我们的兄弟会无处不在，交易者们小心，奉伟大的大独眼巨人（SACLAPS）之命。所以那不是吉米·卡特。那是1868年春天出现在蒙哥马利各处的传单上的信息，
Alabama in the spring of 1868 and the Florida, the apocalyptic tone, it belongs to a recruiting message by the Ku Klux Klan. And Dominic, I guess the Ku Klux Klan is one of those aspects of American history, that even people who know nothing about American history, are. familiar with. So it's white robes, isn't it? It's kind of weird, pointed hoods, burning crosses, lynching black people, of course. And I guess too outsiders, the Ku Klux Klan are the embodiment of the dark side of American history. So very violent, but also very lurid. And there's something, I mean, there's almost something comic. And you get it in that kind of announcement, don't you? Because it's such a mad thing to be saying. The great grand cyclops. I mean, what's all that about?
阿拉巴马州和佛罗里达州，那种末日般的语调，属于三K党的招募信息。多米尼克，我想三K党是美国历史中即使是对美国历史一无所知的人也熟悉的一个方面。是白袍，对吧？还有那种奇怪的尖顶兜帽、燃烧的十字架，当然还有私刑处死黑人。我想对于局外人来说，三K党是美国历史黑暗面的化身。非常暴力，但也非常耸人听闻。而且有些东西，我的意思是，甚至带有一种滑稽感。你在那种公告里能感觉到，对吧？因为说出这些话太疯狂了。伟大的大独眼巨人。我的意思是，这到底是什么？
He's one of the less extravagantly named officers of the Ku Klux Klan. Yeah, because there are some mad ones to come. There are. We've got a lot of goblins to come and what are. And I completely agree with you. The clan is well known even to people who know nothing at all about the context from which it sprung. So, you know, you just have to see a photograph the Ku Klux Klan. You recognize them immediately. The classic thing I think that people on the sort of liberal left in America say is that the clan is un-American. This isn't what America is, that kind of thing. Yeah, this is not America. I mean, actually, there have been three different clans, and I think we can safely say that they are very American. They're deeply rooted in political and social contexts, but in ways that have changed, interestingly,
他是三K党中头衔没那么夸张的官员之一。是的，因为后面还有一些更疯狂的。确实。我们后面还有很多“妖精”，而且……我完全同意你的看法。即使是对三K党产生的背景一无所知的人，也对这个组织很熟悉。所以，你只需要看一张三K党的照片，就能立刻认出他们。我认为美国自由左派人士常说的一点是，三K党是“非美国”的。这不是美国的样子，诸如此类。是的，这不是美国。我的意思是，实际上，历史上出现过三个不同的三K党，我认为我们可以肯定地说，它们是非常“美国”的。它们深深植根于政治和社会背景中，但有趣的是，这些背景随着时间发生了变化。
over time. So the first clan, that's what that reading comes from, was founded in 1866 after the American Civil War in the defeated Confederacy. It was a paramilitary group that was committed to overthrowing the processes. of reconstruction. That's the process of kind of remodeling the southern states. And it was dedicated to the principle of restoring white supremacy over the millions of freed slaves. Then there was a second clan that was founded in 1915, so just before the United States Centers of the First World War. And that was inspired by a film, The Birth of a Nation, by the great director, D.W. Griffith.
第一个三K党，也就是那段文字的来源，成立于1866年美国内战之后，在战败的邦联地区。它是一个准军事组织，致力于推翻重建进程。那是重塑南方各州的过程。它致力于恢复白人至上主义，凌驾于数百万获得自由的奴隶之上。然后是1915年成立的第二个三K党，就在美国参加第一次世界大战之前。它的灵感来自于伟大导演D.W.格里菲斯拍摄的电影《一个国家的诞生》。
And that clan, the second clan, very different in character, much more popular in the industrial north and in the Midwest in states like Indiana and Illinois in cities like Detroit and Chicago. It was very nativist, very anti-Semitic and above all anti-Catholic. White supremacy has always been part of all three clans' message, but they've interpreted that white supremacy in different ways. And for the second clan, it was really above all white Protestant supremacy. So it's a wasp supremacy. Exactly. Its chief targets really were Catholics. And that second clan, I mean, this will surprise people who think of the clan purely as an anti-blind. You know, American South organization. That second clan was by far the biggest and at its peak
那个三K党，即第二个三K党，性质非常不同，在工业化的北方和中西部地区（如印第安纳州和伊利诺伊州，以及底特律和芝加哥等城市）更受欢迎。它非常排外，非常反犹太，最重要的是反天主教。白人至上主义一直是这三个三K党共同的信息，但他们以不同的方式诠释了这种白人至上主义。对于第二个三K党来说，它实际上主要是白人新教徒至上主义。所以是WASP（白人盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒）至上主义。没错。它的主要目标确实是天主教徒。而第二个三K党，我的意思是，这会让那些认为三K党纯粹是一个反黑人、美国南方组织的人感到惊讶。那个第二个三K党是迄今为止规模最大的，在鼎盛时期
it possibly had as many as five million members. I mean, an extraordinarily large and influential organization. And then there's the third clan, which is still kind of staggering on today, which is a far right racist organization formed in the late 40s, basically to fight the civil rights movement. And this, I think, the one that we're all familiar with. So this is a clan that does burn crosses. I mean, the first clan doesn't burn crosses at all. the way. But the third clan, they are easily the least important and interesting of the three incarnations of the clan. Because they're the smallest. Is that the smallest? And they have the least political traction. Whereas the first two clans really matter politically. So let's begin this
它可能拥有多达五百万名成员。我的意思是，这是一个规模极其庞大且影响力巨大的组织。然后是第三个三K党，至今仍在苟延残喘，这是一个在40年代末成立的极右翼种族主义组织，主要是为了对抗民权运动。我认为，这就是我们大家都熟悉的那个。所以这是一个会焚烧十字架的三K党。顺便说一句，第一个三K党根本不焚烧十字架。但第三个三K党，他们无疑是这三个三K党化身中最不重要、最无趣的。因为他们规模最小。是最小的吗？而且他们的政治影响力也最小。而前两个三K党在政治上确实很重要。所以让我们开始本周的
week. So there's a common lineage between the three groups, but they are different. So let's begin with the first one. That's the one we're talking about this week. And this was founded in a place called Pulaski, Tennessee in the summer of 1866. So to give people a sense of the concept, It's just over a year since the end of the American Civil War, and I know this will come as a great shock to our American listeners, but people outside America are not as interested in the American Civil War as they are. So to remind people, the American Civil War saw 11 states in the largely rural south of the United States, tried to break away from the Union to defend the institution of slavery. And in those 11 states, there lived about 9 million people. And just over a third
话题。所以这三个组织之间有共同的血统，但它们是不同的。让我们从第一个开始。这就是我们本周要讨论的。它成立于1866年夏天，地点在田纳西州的普拉斯基。为了让大家了解背景，距离美国内战结束才刚过一年，我知道这对我们的美国听众来说会是一个巨大的冲击，但美国以外的人对美国内战的兴趣并不像他们那么大。所以提醒一下，美国内战中，美国南部大部分农村地区的11个州试图脱离联邦，以捍卫奴隶制。在那11个州里，居住着大约900万人。其中超过三分之一
of those people, so about more than 3 million, were black slaves of African descent or African background. And these people were treated as property. At best, they were treated, they were regarded as children. At worst, they were regarded as little more than animals as not fully human. So that's really important to keep that in your minds the whole time. Another thing to remember, the South is not all just one thing. So the terrain of the South, as it were, both physically and economically differs from place to place, depending basically whether or not there were plantations, specifically cotton plantations. So in some states like South Carolina or Mississippi or Louisiana, slaves made up as much as 60% of the population. But in others, let's say Tennessee or Arkansas,
的人，也就是超过300万，是非洲裔或非洲背景的黑人奴隶。这些人被视为财产。往好了说，他们被视为孩子。往坏了说，他们被视为仅仅是动物，不是完整的人。所以，时刻记住这一点非常重要。另一件要记住的事情是，南方并非铁板一块。所以南方的地形，无论是物理上还是经济上，因地而异，基本上取决于是否有种植园，特别是棉花种植园。因此，在南卡罗来纳州、密西西比州或路易斯安那州等一些州，奴隶占人口的比例高达60%。但在其他州，比如田纳西州或阿肯色州，
there are fewer plantations so they make up about a quarter. But no matter where you're talking about, racial supremacy was absolutely central to white people's identity. and to the political mission of the Confederacy. That is what this is all about. It's what everybody carries in their heads the whole time, the massive separation between black and white. And it sometimes said, oh, the Civil War wasn't just about slavery, blah, blah, blah, blah.
种植园较少，所以他们只占四分之一左右。但无论你在谈论哪里，种族至上主义对于白人的身份认同以及邦联的政治使命来说都是绝对核心的。这就是这一切的全部意义所在。这是每个人时刻都在脑海中铭记的东西，即黑人和白人之间巨大的隔阂。有时人们会说，哦，内战不仅仅是关于奴隶制，等等等等。
I mean, it might not just have been about slavery, but slavery was always at the heart of it. So the vice president of the Confederacy, Alexander Stevens, who came from Georgia, was completely explicit on this point. So just before the war broke out, he gave a very famous speech called the Cornerstone speech. And he said,
我的意思是，它可能不仅仅是关于奴隶制，但奴隶制始终是其核心。因此，来自佐治亚州的邦联副总统亚历山大·斯蒂芬斯在这一点上表达得非常明确。就在战争爆发前，他发表了一场非常著名的演讲，名为“基石演说”。他说，
the cornerstone of the Confederacy is the great truth that the Negro is not equal to the white man, that slavery, subordination to the superior race is his natural and normal condition. And this, our new government, is the first in the history of the world based on this great physical, philosophical and moral truth. Now, lots of people listening to this will find that absolutely abhorrent, not just the language, but also the sentiment. But I think it's really important to remember that for most people in the Confederacy, most white people, that's just a plain scientific and moral fact. They see that as absolutely inarguable. And the scientific dimension of it, Darwin's origin of species had come out a decade before. Before that,
邦联的基石是这样一个伟大的真理：黑人并不等同于白人，奴隶制、对优等种族的从属地位是他自然且正常的状况。而我们这个新政府，是世界历史上第一个基于这一伟大的物理、哲学和道德真理的政府。现在，许多听到这里的人会觉得这绝对令人厌恶，不仅是语言，还有这种情绪。但我认为非常重要的一点是，对于邦联中的大多数人，大多数白人来说，这只是一个平淡的科学和道德事实。他们认为这是绝对无可争辩的。而科学层面，达尔文的《物种起源》在十年前就已经出版了。在此之前，
you have notion spread of the Enlightenment, that there are different races that are at different stages of development. And the moral truth that one race is inferiority of the other is contingent on what the white supremacists in the South see as an objective scientific fact. Yeah, exactly right, exactly, which is why they don't abandon their principles once the war is over. So important to remember, they never think for a moment that they are the villains in this story. They're the victims. Yeah, they're defending a scientific and moral truth, as you say. But they are overwhelmed in the American Civil War by the industrial urban modernity of the North.
你已经有了启蒙运动传播的观念，即不同的种族处于不同的发展阶段。而一个种族优于另一个种族的道德真理，取决于南方白人至上主义者所认为的客观科学事实。是的，完全正确，确实如此，这就是为什么他们在战争结束后并没有放弃他们的原则。记住这一点很重要，他们从未有一刻认为自己是这个故事里的反派。他们是受害者。是的，正如你所说，他们是在捍卫一个科学和道德真理。但他们在内战中被北方工业化、城市化的现代性所压倒。
So by the end of the war, a quarter of a million white southerners have been killed. So that is almost a fifth of the entire adult white population. The economy of the South has been completely destroyed. Most people have lost a huge chunk of their livelihoods or their savings. Their infrastructure has been smashed. Their houses and their farms have been burned to the ground by the Union armies. And of course, they have lost the bit of their property that meant most of them, either economically or kind of psychologically, because all of the slaves had been freed under
所以到战争结束时，有25万南方白人被杀。这几乎占了整个成年白人人口的五分之一。南方的经济被彻底摧毁了。大多数人失去了大部分生计或积蓄。他们的基础设施被粉碎了。他们的房屋和农场被联邦军队烧成了灰烬。当然，他们失去了对他们而言意义最重大的那部分财产，无论是从经济上还是心理上，因为所有的奴隶都在
Abraham Lincoln's Emancipation Proclamation of January 1863. Now, for people who owned slaves, for the white people of the South, this was a gigantic shock, economic shock, political, but also psychological, right? That the, I mean, their whole worldview had been based on owning slaves. But if you were a former slave, this is a moment of tremendous liberation. So the freedmen, as they're called, three million of them. They are, I mean, this is a moment of great excitement. They can taste their freedom for the first time. They can set up their own schools, their own churches.
亚伯拉罕·林肯1863年1月的《解放黑人奴隶宣言》下获得了自由。现在，对于那些拥有奴隶的人，对于南方的白人来说，这是一个巨大的冲击，经济冲击、政治冲击，但也是心理冲击，对吧？因为他们的整个世界观都是建立在拥有奴隶的基础上的。但如果你曾经是一名奴隶，这是一个极其解放的时刻。所以，所谓的“自由人”，有300万之多。他们，我的意思是，这是一个非常令人兴奋的时刻。他们第一次尝到了自由的滋味。他们可以建立自己的学校，自己的教堂。
They can set up institutions. They set up these political education societies called the Union Leagues, in which people will, you know, basically the one or two people who can read, will read newspapers to all the rest, and they'll discuss political ideas, and they'll look forward to voting and to exercising their rights to citizens. And the voting is the key issue, isn't it? because if they vote, then they can get people who will not be in favor of white supremacy. And so then their defeat in the civil war will be entrenched politically.
他们可以建立机构。他们建立了这些名为“联邦联盟”的政治教育协会，人们会，你知道，基本上那一两个识字的人会给其他人读报纸，他们会讨论政治思想，他们会期待投票并行使作为公民的权利。而投票是关键问题，不是吗？因为如果他们投票，那么他们就能选出那些不支持白人至上主义的人。这样，他们在内战中的失败就会在政治上被固化。
Yeah, well, if you're a black freedman in 1866, you're probably going to vote Republican. I mean, you're almost certainly going to vote Republican because the Republican Party is the party that's free due. And so the white Southerners are now looking forward to an age in which I already mentioned in South Carolina or Mississippi, the white population is only 40% of the state. So they will be permanently outnumbered by people who, as they see it, will always vote for their enemies. Anyway, let's get on to the politics of this. So last year, we did a series about the assassination of Abraham Lincoln. We talked about how when Lincoln died, he died without any very clear plan about what he was going to do with the South.
是的，好吧，如果你是1866年的一名黑人自由人，你很可能会投票给共和党。我的意思是，你几乎肯定会投票给共和党，因为共和党是那个带来自由的政党。所以南方白人现在正期待着一个时代，我刚才提到在南卡罗来纳州或密西西比州，白人人口只占该州的40%。所以他们将永远被那些在他们看来总是会投票给他们敌人的人所压倒。无论如何，让我们谈谈这背后的政治。去年，我们做了一个关于亚伯拉罕·林肯遇刺的系列节目。我们谈到了林肯去世时，他对于如何处理南方没有任何非常明确的计划。
Now, his successor was a guy called Andrew Johnson, who was a unionist from Tennessee. So he's a southerner, but unusually he backed the union. And Andrew Johnson has this horrendous inheritance Because first of all, he has to integrate the Confederacy back into the union. How are you going to do that? But he also has to work out what he's going to do with the 3.5 million former slaves. Because, of course, they've been freed, but what are they going to do? What jobs are they going to do?
现在，他的继任者是一个叫安德鲁·约翰逊的人，他是一位来自田纳西州的联邦主义者。所以他是一个南方人，但不同寻常的是他支持联邦。而安德鲁·约翰逊继承了一份可怕的遗产，因为首先，他必须将邦联重新整合进联邦。你打算怎么做？但他还必须弄清楚如何处理那350万前奴隶。因为，当然，他们已经获得了自由，但他们要做什么？他们要做什么工作？
Where are they going to live? And there's a government organization called the Freed Men's Bureau, which has been set up to deal with them. But what that means, nobody knows. Now, to the horror of many of Lincoln's old allies, some listeners may remember that when we did the assassination series last year, we quoted a lot of sort of radical Republicans as they were called saying, oh, I think Johnson's going to be better than Lincoln. You know, some of them were actually saying, thank God Lincoln's gone, because we think Johnson will be tougher on the South, and that's what we want. Well, they were quite wrong about that. He's very keen to integrate the southern states as quickly as possible.
他们要住在哪里？有一个名为“自由人局”的政府组织，它是为了处理这些问题而设立的。但这意味着什么，没人知道。现在，令林肯的许多老盟友感到震惊的是，一些听众可能还记得，去年我们做遇刺系列节目时，我们引用了很多所谓的激进共和党人的话，说，哦，我认为约翰逊会比林肯做得更好。你知道，他们中有些人甚至在说，感谢上帝林肯走了，因为我们认为约翰逊会对南方更强硬，而这正是我们想要的。好吧，他们完全错了。他非常热衷于尽快整合南方各州。
And at one point, he's offering thousands of pardons every day to fly. former Southerners to bring them back in. But by 1866, so that's a year after the end of the war, the Confederate South is still a very chaotic and violent place. So the former owners are trying to regain control over what they see as their lost property. So they are whipping and beating and shooting and hanging African Americans in large numbers. Dominic, I'm just wondering, you say it's chaotic, this is in the wake of a war, there must be enormous amounts of weaponry around, why are the freed slaves not tooling up and particularly where the majority kind of, you know, fighting back? That's a good question, actually. In some places they do. So,
有一次，他每天提供数千份赦免，给那些前南方人，让他们回来。但到了1866年，也就是战争结束一年后，邦联南方仍然是一个非常混乱和暴力的地方。所以前奴隶主正试图重新夺回对他们所谓的“失去的财产”的控制权。因此，他们正在大规模地鞭打、殴打、枪杀和绞死非裔美国人。多米尼克，我只是在想，你说它很混乱，这是在战争之后，周围一定有大量的武器，为什么获得自由的奴隶没有武装起来，特别是大多数人是否在反击？这是一个好问题，实际上。在某些地方他们确实这样做了。所以，
and there are stories about black people arming themselves, forming militias and so on. There is a great anxiety on the part of white southerners that these union leagues are actually a kind of front for a race war that their former slaves will, wage against them and so on. So I think to some degree, the answer is some of them are tooling up at least, but by and large, most of them don't want to have a war. You know, they've got what they wanted, right? They want to just be able to enjoy their freedom. They've been absolutely brutalized by this appalling system in which they've been treated as chattels. Now they've been freed. I mean, there are course cases of people exacting revenge and there are lots of, you know, accounts of
有一些关于黑人武装自己、组建民兵等等的故事。南方白人非常担心这些“联邦联盟”实际上是一场种族战争的幌子，他们的前奴隶会向他们发动战争等等。所以我认为在某种程度上，答案是他们中有些人确实武装起来了，但总的来说，大多数人不想打仗。你知道，他们得到了他们想要的，对吧？他们只想能够享受他们的自由。他们被这种可怕的制度彻底摧残，在这种制度下他们被当作动产对待。现在他们获得了自由。我的意思是，当然有人们寻求报复的案例，也有很多关于
violence on both sides, of course, but by and large, most of the freed people, as it were, just want to get on, you know, they want to get on with their lives. You know, that's what you would want to do, right, if you've been freed. When you get out of prison, your first instinct is not usually, I want to go and kill the jailer. It's, I want to taste the fruits of freedom. Anyway, just last word on the political context. So by 1866 or so, the South very chaotic. Also, Washington politics, very chaotic.
双方暴力的描述，当然，但总的来说，大多数获得自由的人，正如人们所说，只是想继续生活，你知道，他们想继续他们的生活。你知道，如果你获得了自由，这就是你会想做的事，对吧？当你出狱时，你的第一直觉通常不是“我想去杀了狱卒”。而是，“我想品尝自由的果实”。无论如何，关于政治背景的最后一句话。所以到1866年左右，南方非常混乱。华盛顿的政治也非常混乱。
Many of Lincoln's old allies, the so-called radical Republicans have lost faith in President Johnson. they think not unreasonably that he's going to undo their victory in the Civil War, that he's going to scrap the process of reconstruction or accelerate it so quickly that it'd be meaningless. So they are determined to take control of reconstruction away from him, and we'll see how that plays out in the second half. So all this is the background for what happens in Pulaski, Tennessee in the summer of 1866. Now, Tennessee is an unusual state by Confederate standards. It had fewer slaves than most other Confederate states. it only had about one in four of its population was black.
林肯的许多老盟友，所谓的激进共和党人，已经对约翰逊总统失去了信心。他们认为，这并非没有道理，他会撤销他们在内战中的胜利，他会废除重建进程，或者加速它，以至于它变得毫无意义。所以他们决心从他手中夺取重建的控制权，我们将看看这在下半部分是如何发展的。所以所有这些都是1866年夏天发生在田纳西州普拉斯基事件的背景。现在，田纳西州在邦联标准中是一个不寻常的州。它的奴隶比大多数其他邦联州都要少。它只有大约四分之一的人口是黑人。
In East Tennessee, which is Appalachian Mountains, there were very few slaves at all because the terrain was no good for cotton plantations. As a result, there are kind of lots of small farms owned by white people who tend to be unionists, so to support the United States. So Tennessee had a bigger loyalist population. It was the first Confederate state to come under union military rule. And at the end of the Civil War, the governor of Tennessee is a bloke called Parson Brownlow.
在东田纳西州，也就是阿巴拉契亚山脉地区，几乎没有什么奴隶，因为那里的地形不适合种植棉花。结果，那里有很多白人拥有的自耕农场，他们倾向于成为联邦主义者，也就是支持美国。所以田纳西州有更多的效忠派人口。它是第一个处于联邦军事统治下的邦联州。在内战结束时，田纳西州的州长是一个叫帕森·布朗洛的家伙。
And he was called Parson because he'd been a Methodist horse preacher, which meant that he basically just sort of trudged around on a horse. He wasn't preaching to horses. No, preaching to revivalist meetings. Francis Fassisi. Exactly. Parson Brownlow is a very abrasive, stubborn, vituperative man. Everybody agrees.
他被称为“帕森”（牧师），因为他曾是一名卫理公会的巡回传教士，这意味着他基本上就是骑着马到处走。他不是在给马传教。不，是在复兴聚会上讲道。弗朗西斯·法西西。没错。帕森·布朗洛是一个非常尖刻、固执、谩骂的人。每个人都同意这一点。
He is a difficult customer. But he is allied to the radical Republicans in Congress. And he is taking quite a hard line on the former Confederates. So he has stripped all former Confederates of the vote. So the former slaves now have the vote and the slave owners don't. Right. Well, this is exactly, as we shall see, this is a key part of the context for the emergence of the clan. So at the end of 198066, Tennessee was the first former rebel state that was allowed back into the union, allowed to rejoin the union, sent people to Congress.
他是一个难对付的人。但他与国会的激进共和党人结盟。他对前邦联成员采取了相当强硬的立场。所以他剥夺了所有前邦联成员的投票权。所以前奴隶现在有了投票权，而奴隶主没有。好吧，正如我们将要看到的，这正是三K党出现的关键背景。1866年底，田纳西州是第一个被允许回到联邦、被允许重新加入联邦并向国会派遣人员的前叛乱州。
And so they all get their votes back. Not initially. They do later on. It's not a very happy place, Tennessee. There's this great sense of victimhood in the middle and west of the state where people are lost their slaves, and they've lost their social status, and they've lost a lot of money. And there are parts of the state where law and order is fragile at best. So there are bands of kind of vigilantes who are known as regulators who are roaming around attacking Republicans
所以他们都拿回了投票权。起初没有。他们后来才拿回。田纳西州不是一个快乐的地方。在该州的中部和西部，有一种巨大的受害者心态，人们失去了奴隶，失去了社会地位，损失了很多钱。而且该州有些地方的法律和秩序充其量是脆弱的。所以有一些被称为“监管者”的治安维持者在到处游荡，攻击共和党人
and attacking the freedmen. And you get that in almost every southern state. And one of these places where law and order has broken down is Giles County. So this is on the border with Alabama, the south of the state. About 30,000 people live in Giles County. Just under half of them were slaves. The only vaguely sizable town is this place, Pulaski, which is a kind of quite rough and ready kind of place, about 2,000 people. The authorities in Pulaski are very, very racist. The sheriff still goes around boasting that he's whipping, he will whip his former slaves if he sees them. And the local agent of the freedmen's bureau, so that's the agency set up to look after the African Americans. He reported back to headquarters, the white people do all they can
并攻击自由人。你在几乎每一个南方州都能看到这种情况。而法律和秩序崩溃的地方之一是贾尔斯县。这就在阿拉巴马州的边界上，在该州的南部。贾尔斯县居住着大约3万人。其中不到一半是奴隶。唯一勉强算得上城镇的地方是普拉斯基，这是一个相当粗犷的地方，大约有2000人。普拉斯基的当局非常、非常种族主义。警长仍然到处吹嘘说，如果他看到前奴隶，他就会鞭打他们。而当地的自由人局代理人，也就是那个为了照顾非裔美国人而设立的机构，他向总部报告说，白人尽其所能
to degrade the freedmen and to keep them down to what they see fit to call their proper place. And it's in this place in Pulaski in Jars County that the Ku Klux Klan is born. And it happened in the law office of Judge Thomas M. Jones, probably in late May, 1866. And there were six people involved that very first meeting. They were the judge's son, Calvin, a man called Captain John C. Lester, Major James R. Crow, John B. Kennedy, Richard R. Reid and Frank O. McCord. It's a brilliant book on The First Clown by Alan Trellise, which is kind of the definitive book,
去贬低自由人，并把他们压制在他们认为合适的所谓“应有的位置”上。正是在贾尔斯县的普拉斯基这个地方，三K党诞生了。它发生在托马斯·M·琼斯法官的律师事务所里，可能是在1866年5月下旬。最初的那次会议有六个人参加。他们是法官的儿子卡尔文、一个叫约翰·C·莱斯特上尉的人、詹姆斯·R·克罗少校、约翰·B·肯尼迪、理查德·R·里德和弗兰克·O·麦科德。艾伦·特雷利斯写了一本关于第一个三K党的精彩著作，这算是权威著作，
but it's been supplemented by a historian called Elaine France Parsons, who's looked into the backgrounds of these guys. They were from what was seen as good families in the locality. They were well-educated. They were all quite young, so they're in their mid-20s or early 30s. They'd all fought for the Confederacy. But although they're Army veterans,
但它被一位名叫伊莱恩·弗朗斯·帕森斯的历史学家补充了，她调查了这些人的背景。他们来自当地所谓的“好家庭”。他们受过良好的教育。他们都很年轻，大约在20多岁到30岁出头。他们都为邦联战斗过。但尽管他们是退伍军人，
I don't think they see this as a paramilitary organisation. This is not the Frye Corps. They don't see it as a veterans organisation or anything like that. It's basically a local social club. Well, I was looking at the other names that they were planning on coming up with, and there was the secret circle, the Pulaski Social Club, and the Thespians. I think the Ku Klux Klan would have been a lot less menacing if they'd been called the Thespians. The Thespians, yeah, you're not wrong.
我不认为他们把这看作是一个准军事组织。这不是自由军团。他们不认为这是一个退伍军人组织之类的。这基本上就是一个当地的社交俱乐部。好吧，我看了他们计划使用的其他名字，有“秘密圈子”、“普拉斯基社交俱乐部”和“戏剧家”。我认为如果他们叫“戏剧家”，三K党就不会那么有威胁性了。“戏剧家”，是的，你说得对。
So it's a social club, and the reason they've chosen that name, obviously a really important part of it is it's exotic but it's also very much of the time. So for almost a century, American University fraternities had adopted Greek names, so the most famous Phi Beta Kappa. You know, it's still going, I think. And one of those fraternities, one of the best known actually in the South in the early 19th century was a fraternity called the Ku Kloss Adelfon, which was originally at the University of North Carolina and it spread through the south, but then kind of fell away in the 1850s and 1860s.
所以这是一个社交俱乐部，他们选择那个名字的原因，显然其中一个非常重要的部分是它既充满异国情调，又非常符合时代潮流。近一个世纪以来，美国大学的兄弟会一直采用希腊语名称，最著名的是Phi Beta Kappa。你知道，我想它还在运作。而在19世纪初的南方，最著名的兄弟会之一是一个叫“Ku Kloss Adelfon”的兄弟会，它最初在北卡罗来纳大学，并传播到南方，但在1850年代和1860年代逐渐消失了。
Now, Ku Kloss comes from the Greek kind of ring or circle, I think it means, and that's where you get Ku Klux. And then they just chose K, with a capital K, you know, because of the alliteration. Nothing, it's as simple as that. There's an element of a college fraternity from the beginning. They, their meeting place is this kind of derelict house, this grove, rather, next to a derelict house. And they call it the den.
现在，“Ku Kloss”来自希腊语中的环或圆圈，我想是这个意思，这就是“Ku Klux”的由来。然后他们只是选择了一个大写的K，你知道，因为头韵。没什么，就这么简单。从一开始就有大学兄弟会的成分。他们，他们的聚会地点是那个废弃房子旁边的一个树林。他们称之为“巢穴”。
They all give themselves titles, so that's where you get the Grand Cyclops, the Grand Magi, the Grand Turk, the Grand Exchequer, and two Lictors. And they dress up. And they dress up not just in the canonical outfit. So they do wear the white mask with the holes, the sort of the pointed kind of hat and the long robe. But we know that they wore other things too. So there's an early quote. They wore Spanish jackets and wide trousers with a cap and feathers. That's interesting, isn't it?
他们都给自己起了头衔，这就是“大独眼巨人”、“大贤者”、“大土耳其人”、“大财务官”和两名“执法官”的由来。而且他们会打扮起来。他们不仅穿那种典型的服装。他们确实戴着有孔的白色面具、那种尖顶的帽子和长袍。但我们也知道他们还穿了其他东西。所以有一个早期的引述。他们穿着西班牙夹克和宽大的裤子，戴着插着羽毛的帽子。这很有趣，不是吗？
The Spanish jacket? Because that pointed conical white thing, I mean, it comes from Spanish Catholic practice. You wear it in Holy Week and process through the streets. Am I overthinking it? This is a big Spanish thing. I think it's just a fun, exotic costume. It's japerie. It is slightly public school japerie.
西班牙夹克？因为那个尖尖的圆锥形白色东西，我的意思是，它来自西班牙天主教的习俗。你在圣周期间穿上它，在街上游行。我是不是想多了？这是一个很大的西班牙特色。我认为这只是一个有趣的、充满异国情调的服装。这是一种恶作剧。这确实有点像公立学校的恶作剧。
You know, they're the young bloods of the town. They've come back from the war. They've got nothing to do. They're dressing up and they are making up silly rituals themselves. And this is what a lot of people do in 19th century in America. So just to emphasize, it is not at this point a racist organization. It's just for fun. It's a social organization.
你知道，他们是镇上的年轻血气方刚的人。他们从战争中回来。他们无事可做。他们打扮起来，自己编造愚蠢的仪式。这就是19世纪美国许多人所做的事情。所以要强调的是，此时它还不是一个种族主义组织。这只是为了好玩。这是一个社交组织。
Well, this is a complicated question. It's a racist organization insofar as all the people who are in it are racists. They are white supremacists who believe that white supremacy is the cornerstone of their society. However, that's not why they've set this up. There's no doubt they would have said racist things when they're hanging around, you know, having their japs. but that's not why they've done this. The equivalent of a kind of a Tory club or a Whig club in London, that kind of thing. A little bit, yeah.
好吧，这是一个复杂的问题。它是一个种族主义组织，因为其中所有的人都是种族主义者。他们是白人至上主义者，相信白人至上主义是他们社会的基石。然而，这不是他们建立这个组织的原因。毫无疑问，当他们聚在一起，你知道，进行恶作剧时，他们会说种族主义的话，但这不是他们这样做的原因。相当于伦敦的一种托利党俱乐部或辉格党俱乐部，诸如此类。有点像，是的。
Your political affiliations are why you meet up, but you're not sitting there discussing politics all the time. Yes, I think that's probably right. Now, how it spread, the first organisers were very vague about this. I think possibly because they were a little bit embarrassed by its later associations with violence, even though they shared the political aims of the people who practice that violence. But what seemed to happen is other people in neighbouring counties heard about this den of these guys to dress up. And they said, oh, we'd like to do that too. And they sort of got permission or they got probably just verbal permission from the Grand Cyclops.
你的政治倾向是你聚在一起的原因，但你并不是一直坐在那里讨论政治。是的，我想这可能是对的。至于它是如何传播的，最初的组织者对此非常含糊。我想可能是因为他们对后来与暴力的联系感到有点尴尬，尽管他们与那些实施暴力的人有着共同的政治目标。但似乎发生的事情是，邻近县的其他人在听说这些家伙打扮起来的“巢穴”后。他们说，哦，我们也想那样做。于是他们得到了许可，或者可能只是从大独眼巨人那里得到了口头许可。
For the Grand Cyclops to set up their own dens. And so by the late summer of 1866, there are other KKK dens. There were very, very few contemporary accounts of them. But Alan Trellis quotes a man from Alabama who says he saw them at a midnight picnic. that autumn. He remembered them wearing pretty and showy costumes, hats decorated with stars and spangles. So they're basically dressed as conjurers or something. And I quote, it seemed to be a thing of amusement. I never heard anything in connection with it as a political organization. But of course, it's going to be very difficult to stay as an non-political organization in a world in which, you know, politics is so
让大独眼巨人建立他们自己的巢穴。所以到了1866年夏末，出现了其他的KKK巢穴。关于他们的当代记录非常、非常少。但艾伦·特雷利斯引用了一位阿拉巴马州人的话，他说他在那年秋天的一个午夜野餐上看到了他们。他记得他们穿着漂亮而显眼的服装，帽子上装饰着星星和亮片。所以他们基本上打扮得像魔术师之类的。我引用一下，“这似乎是一种娱乐。我从未听说过它与政治组织有任何联系。”但当然，在一个政治如此充满威胁的世界里，要保持作为一个非政治组织是非常困难的。但正如你所说，它不是自由军团。它不是一种公开的准军事组织。好吧，还没到那个地步。还没到。我想这就是重点。所以，在田纳西州和南方大部分地区，政治温度正在升高。所以那个冬天，1866年底，
charged with menace. But as you say, it's not the Freikor. It's not a kind of over- covertly paramilitary organization. Well, not yet. Not yet. I think that's the point. So across Tennessee and much of the south, political temperature is rising. So that winter, at the end of 1866,
有很多针对黑人自由人和白人联邦主义者（也就是白人共和党人）的暴力袭击。到了1867年初，布朗洛州长，帕森·布朗洛，就是我刚才描述的那个非常固执的人，他发表了一份公告：“我对叛徒没有任何让步，对穿着长袍的刺客没有任何妥协。”
there are a lot of violent attacks on black freedmen and on white unionists, that's to say, white Republicans. And by early 1867, Governor Brownlow, Parsons Brownlow, who's this very stubborn man, as I already described, he issued a proclamation, I have no concessions to make to traitors, no compromises to offer to assassins and robes.
“所列举的暴行必须且将会停止，”将会用大写字母书写。他说，“我将呼吁联邦军队。我将组织州民兵。”这对前邦联成员来说总是很可怕的，提到州民兵，因为他们知道根据定义，它将由武装的黑人组成。而这正是比任何事情都更让他们感到恐惧的事情。回到你的观点，汤姆，关于黑人获得武器的恐惧。这是南方白人最大的噩梦。
The outrages enumerated must and shall cease, shall in capital letters. And he said, I'm going to call for federal troops. I'm going to organize a state militia. This is always terrifying for former Confederates, the talk of a state militia, because they know that by definition, it would consist of armed black men. And that is the one thing that terrifies them more than anything else. Going back to your point, Tom, about the fears of black people getting weapons. this is the single biggest nightmare for a white southerner.
布朗洛说，“我将确保所有黑人在下次选举前都有投票权。”现在，这不仅没有平息局势，反而彻底激怒了他们，因为前邦联成员此时加倍反抗。在他们看来，布朗洛基本上已经对他们说：“我将通过军事专制进行统治，我将引入更多的军队，我将给予黑人投票权。”所以，你将永远无法再赢得选举。因此，在这一点上，他们说：“好吧，在这种情况下，我们有权建立我们自己的准军事反对派来对抗你。”这就是1867年春天，
And Brownlow says, I'm going to make sure that all black men have the vote before the next election. Now, instead of calming things, this absolutely inflames them because the ex-Confederates at this point double down. As they see it, Brownlow has basically said to them, I'm going to rule by military despotism, I'm going to bring in more troops, and I'm going to give black people the vote. So, you'll never win an election again. And so at this point, they say, well, in that case, we're entitled to raise out. own paramilitary opposition to you. And this is the point in the spring of 1867, when the
三K党真正演变成一个明确的政治组织的时候。关键时刻，这是一个令人难以置信的事实。它发生在以麦斯威尔咖啡命名的那家酒店。所以我们对这次会议了解不多，因为他们没有保留记录。基本上，普拉斯基巢穴的大独眼巨人召集了一些其他的KKK巢穴。现在，与此同时，或者就在之后，在纳什维尔举行了一次民主党州代表大会。当时的民主党人自称为“保守派”。太混乱了。所以可能在这些主流政治人物、民主党人到达纳什维尔和KKK代表提前几天到达之间存在重叠，
clan really evolves into an explicitly political organisation. And the key moment, this is an incredible fact. It took place at the hotel after which Maxwell House coffee is named. So we don't know that much about this meeting because they didn't keep records. Basically, the Grand Cyclops of the Pulaski Den summoned some of the other clan dens. Now, at the same time, or just afterwards, there was a sort of basically a democratic state convention in Nashville. The Democrats at this point were calling themselves the conservatives. So confusing. So there's probably an overlap between some of these sort of mainstream political people, the Democratic Party arriving in Nashville and the KKK delegates arriving a few days before
因为实际上，第一个三K党和南方的民主党之间有大量的重叠。关键人物似乎是一位前邦联军队准将，名叫乔治·W·戈登。戈登，汤姆。戈登将军肯定不会是个坏人，多米尼克。告诉我不是这样。我知道在节目中有一位戈登将军让历史上的戈登将军们失望了，这很令人难过。所以这位戈登将军，乔治·W·戈登，他是战争结束时最年轻的邦联将军。他当时31岁。他回到普拉斯基成为了一名律师。他为三K党写了一份新的蓝图。它被称为“处方”。基本上，我知道你是漫威超级英雄电影的忠实粉丝，
because there's a huge amount of overlap actually between this first clan and the Democratic Party in the South. And the key figure seems to have been former Brigadier, General in the Confederate Army called George W. Gordon. Gordon, Tom. Surely a General Gordon can't be a bad man, Dominic. Tell me it ain't so. I know it's sad to have a General Gordon on the show who's letting the General Gordon's of history down. So this General Gordon, George W. Gordon, he was the youngest Confederate General at the war's end. He was 31 years old. And he came back to Pulaski to become a lawyer. And he wrote a new blueprint for the clan. It was called its prescript. And basically, I know you're a big fan of the Marvel superhero films.
这就像是复仇者联盟或其他超级英雄团队的大型行政图表。所以它是这样运作的。如果你是三K党的普通成员，你就是一个“食尸鬼”，属于一个巢穴。每个巢穴由一名大独眼巨人和两名“夜鹰”领导。天哪，不是两名夜鹰。是的，两名夜鹰，不仅仅是一个。还有省的大巨人，以及四名“妖精”。
and this is like a massive administrative chart for the Avengers or something or some team of superheroes. So this is how it works. If you're an ordinary member of the Ku Klux Klan, you are a ghoul and you belong to a den. And each den is headed by a grand cyclops and two nighthawks. God, not two nighthawks. Yeah, two nighthawks, not just one. There is the grand giant of the province and four goblins.
然后他们上面有领地的大泰坦和四名“复仇女神”。然后是王国的大龙。王国就是州。还有八名“九头蛇”。然后他们上面，有帝国的大巫师和他的10名“精灵”。而帝国就是美国南方。你知道这是什么吗？这是那些讨厌托尔金且从未读过他作品的人。
Then above them there's a grand titan of the dominion and four furies. then there's the grand dragon of the realm. The realm is the state. And there's eight hydras. And then above them, there is the grand wizard of the empire and his 10 genie. And the empire is the American South. You know what it is? It's people who hate Tolkien and have never read him.
这就是他们认为《指环王》的样子。这更像是C.S.刘易斯，不是吗？因为C.S.刘易斯把所有东西都扔进去了。他有圣诞老人，他有萨特，他有各种东西。这就是这个组织的样子。因为还有，还有一大堆其他的职位，我真的不知道它们属于哪里。
It's what they think Lord of the Rings is like. It's more sort of C.S. Lewis, isn't it? Because C.S. Lewis throws everything at it. He's got Father Christmas in there. He's got satires. He's got whatever. That's what this is. Because there's also, there's a whole load of other offices that I don't really know where they fit in.
有大土耳其人，有大贤者，有大哨兵。然后，虽然我很喜欢这个，但他们设立了两个内部法庭，如果你是一名官员并且做错了事，就会审判你。如果你只是一个普通的食尸鬼，那么你将由“半人马委员会”审判。所以他们还发布了一份关于三K党宗旨的正式声明。现在，你提到了沃尔特·司各特。这是经典的沃尔特·司各特。这是一个骑士精神、人道、仁慈和爱国主义的机构，
There's Grand Turks, they're Grand Magi, there are Grand Sentinels. And then, while I love this well, they've set up two internal tribunals, which tries you if you're an officer and you've done something wrong. And if you're just an ordinary gall, then you're tried by the Council of Centaurs. So they also issue a formal statement of the clan's purpose. Now, you mentioned Walter Scott. This is classic Walter Scott. This is an institution of chivalry, humanity, mercy and patriotism,
在其天才和原则中体现了所有在行为上具有骑士精神、在情感上高尚、在男子气概上慷慨、在目标上爱国的品质。其目标是保护弱者、无辜者和无助者，使其免受无法无天、暴力和残暴者的侮辱、错误和暴行。
embodying in its genius and its principles all that is chivalric in conduct, noble in sentiment, generous in manhood and patriotic in purpose. Its goals are to protect the weak, the innocents and the innocents and the defenseless from the indignities and wrongs and outrages, the lawless, the violent, and the brutal.
但大概当它说“弱者、无辜者和无助者”时，指的不是前奴隶。不，不。它是在保护白人免受它所认为的前奴隶及其在共和党和联邦军队中的盟友的暴政。
But presumably when it says the weak, the innocent and the defenceless, it's not referring to former slaves. No, no. It's defending white people from what it sees as the tyranny of the former slaves and their allies in the Republican Party and the Union Army.
它说的是所有教科书式的南方言论。这就是南方人在内战前和内战期间所说的话。我们是怀旧、骑士精神、古老英格兰和故土价值观的力量，对抗北方资本主义冷酷无情的机器。而且，我们是这里的受害者。哦，是的。我们是受害者，这实际上是所有三个三K党的核心。而且实际上，有些人听到这里会说，你知道，他们夸大其词了。
And it says all textbook Southern stuff. This is what the Southerners were saying before and during the Civil War. We are the forces of nostalgia, of chivalry, the values of old England and the old country against the soulless machine of northern capitalism. And also, we are the victims here. Oh, yeah. We are the victims is so central to all three clans. actually. And actually, some people listen to this will say, you know, they're over-agging this.
上面写着所有教科书式的南方论调。这就是南方人在南北战争前和战争期间所说的。我们是怀旧和骑士精神的力量，是古老英格兰和故土的价值观，对抗北方资本主义那冷酷无情的机器。而且，我们才是受害者。哦，是的。我们是受害者，这实际上是所有三个三K党派系的核心。事实上，有些人听了会说，你知道，他们有点夸大其词了。
There's nothing very racist about this. But the ten questions that you have to answer to become a ghoul, rather give the game away. Have you ever belonged to the Republican Party? Did you serve in the Union Army and the war? Do you oppose black equality? Do you support the constitutional rights of the South? And what that basically means is, are you know, are you on board to reverse the result of the war, to reverse the process? of reconstruction and to reimpose white supremacy and the subordination of African Americans. Then a few weeks after this Maxwell House meeting, this group gets its figurehead. And the figurehead is the first and only grand wizard of the first clan. And this is another former Confederate general
这并没有什么种族主义色彩。但为了成为食尸鬼而必须回答的十个问题，反而暴露了他们的意图。你曾经是共和党党员吗？你在内战中为联邦军队服役过吗？你反对黑人平等吗？你支持南方的宪法权利吗？这基本上意味着，你是否愿意推翻战争的结果，推翻重建进程，并重新强加白人至上主义和非裔美国人的从属地位。在这次麦克斯韦之家会议几周后，这个组织就有了它的傀儡领袖。而这位傀儡领袖就是第一个，也是唯一一个三K党大巫师。这也是另一位前南方邦联将军。
called Nathan Bedford Forest. So he's top Klansman. It's the Grand Wizard. You can't get bigger than the Grand Wizard. Were you following that administrative chart, Tom? So there isn't a kind of Sauron equivalent. Now, he is Sauron. He is Sauron. He completely is.
名叫内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特。所以他是三K党的头目。他是大巫师。你不可能比大巫师职位更高了。汤姆，你有在看那张行政图表吗？所以并没有索伦那样的对应人物。不，他就是索伦。他就是索伦。他完全就是。
So Nathan Bedford Forest was from Tennessee. He's a former plantation owner. He's a former slave trader. He had really, you know, rocketed up in the Confederate Army. He'd enlisted as a private and rose to become a cavalry general. And he was nicknamed the Wizard of the Saddle for his swashbuckling style. So wizardry is very much his thing, then? Very much his thing.
所以内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特来自田纳西州。他是一位前种植园主。他是一位前奴隶贩子。他在南方邦联军队中确实，你知道，平步青云。他以列兵身份入伍，后来晋升为骑兵将军。他因其勇猛的风格而被昵称为“马鞍上的巫师”。所以巫术确实是他的拿手好戏？非常拿手。
Although there was a dark side to this guy. So Northerners saw him as a war criminal because there was one particular incident to place, called Fort Pillow in 1864, where the union sort of garrison or whatever had surrendered. Many of its troops were black, and Nathan Bedford Forrest's men had allegedly tortured and then hacked them to death, hundreds of them after they had surrendered. Historians still argue about this, but my personal view is he definitely did it. Nathan Bedford Forrest had ended the war fighting down in the deep south. He disbanded his troops when he heard about Robert E. Lee's surrender.
尽管这家伙也有黑暗的一面。北方人视他为战犯，因为1864年发生了一起特定的事件，叫做皮洛堡战役，当时联邦的驻军投降了。许多士兵是黑人，据称内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特的手下在他们投降后，对数百人进行了折磨并将其砍死。历史学家对此仍有争议，但我的个人观点是他绝对干了。内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特在深南部结束了战争。当他听说罗伯特·E·李投降的消息时，他解散了他的部队。
So actually, the fact that he gave up so late adds to his luster for the southern public. Like a lot of former Confederate officers, he then put his money into railroads. Everybody does this in this period. So he's just sort of become a railroad speculator. It's not clear whether he volunteered to join the clan or he was invited, but either way, he became the perfect public face for it. Because to the white southern public, Nathan Bedford Forrest is the incarnation of the swashbuckling Confederate officer who fights to the very end.
事实上，他投降得如此之晚，反而增加了他在南方公众眼中的光环。像许多前南方邦联军官一样，他后来把钱投进了铁路。这个时期每个人都这么做。所以他只是变成了一个铁路投机者。目前还不清楚他是自愿加入三K党还是被邀请的，但无论如何，他成了该组织完美的公众形象。因为对于南方白人公众来说，内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特是那位战斗到最后一刻的勇猛邦联军官的化身。
But he's really just a figurehead. You know, that's the point with all the clans, actually, is their local groups make all the running. There's never really any very strong, coherent central organisation. And so it's very decentralized, which in turn must make it hard to kind of stamp out. Yeah, how do you stamp it out when there's no one to, you know, there's no single person to talk to?
但他实际上只是一个傀儡。你知道，其实所有三K党组织的重点在于，都是地方团体在主导一切。从来没有一个非常强大、连贯的中央组织。所以它是非常分散的，这反过来一定使它很难被根除。是的，当没有一个人，你知道，没有一个单一的人可以对话时，你怎么根除它呢？
So now we've got to the summer of 1867, just as we approach the break. And the clan is still very localized, but it has definitely now become much more public and much more political. So the Pulaski Citizen newspaper, for example, is running regular reports on clan meetings. On the 5th of June 1867, there is the first clan public parade. About 75 clansmen marching through the town in costume.
所以现在我们到了1867年的夏天，就在我们接近休息时间的时候。三K党仍然非常地方化，但它现在肯定已经变得更加公开和更加政治化了。例如，《普拉斯基公民报》正在定期报道三K党的会议。1867年6月5日，举行了第一次三K党公开游行。大约75名三K党成员穿着戏服穿过城镇。
The report in the local paper, as so many of these things, sounds absolutely demented. Tom, do you want to read it in your splendid southern accent? The column was led by the Grand Cyclops, who had on a flowing white robe, a white hat, about 18 inches high. He had a very venerable and benevolent-looking face, and long silvery locks. Next, they followed two of the tallest men out of jail. One of them had on a robe of many colors with a hideous mask and a transparent hat. They conversed in Dutch, Hebrew, or some other language. No two of them were dressed alike, all having on my mouth.
当地报纸的报道，像许多这类事情一样，听起来完全是疯了。汤姆，你想用你那华丽的南方口音读一下吗？队伍由大独眼巨人领导，他穿着一件飘逸的白色长袍，戴着一顶约18英寸高的白色帽子。他有一张非常庄严和慈祥的脸，还有长长的银色发卷。接下来，他们跟着两个从监狱里出来的最高的人。其中一个人穿着一件五颜六色的长袍，戴着一个可怕的面具和一顶透明的帽子。他们用荷兰语、希伯来语或其他某种语言交谈。没有两个人的穿着是一样的，所有人都戴着我的嘴。
And some sort of fanciful costume. Yeah, interesting there that they're not, they're no two dressed alike. So there's no uniform. They're not all wearing white robes. They are wearing, they're just basically wearing fancy dress. And that is so sinister, isn't it?
还有某种奇装异服。是的，有趣的是他们没有，没有两个人的穿着是一样的。所以没有统一的制服。他们并不是都穿着白色长袍。他们穿着，他们基本上只是穿着奇装异服。这太阴险了，不是吗？
I mean, it's so sinister. It's kind of like they're dressing up as clowns or something, which they will be doing in due course. But I mean, it's much more frightening to be attacked, I think, by, you know, a bunch of people dressed up as clowns, say, than just by your everyday thug. Yeah, I guess that is true. actually. If a clown beat you up, that'd be really terrifying. That'd be absolutely frightening.
我的意思是，这太阴险了。这有点像他们打扮成小丑之类的，他们以后也会这么做。但我的意思是，我认为被一群打扮成小丑的人攻击，比被普通的暴徒攻击更令人恐惧。是的，我想那确实是真的。实际上，如果一个小丑揍你，那会非常可怕。那绝对会令人毛骨悚然。
Now, at this point, they haven't yet really started beating people up. Tennessee has elections that August, but they're quite quiet. Now, why is that? It's actually because the local sort of ex-Confederates are hoping, madly, it's a sign how much they've internalized their own rhetoric. They are hoping that their former slaves will vote with their masters. They sort of saying to themselves, well, they know what's best for them. They'll, they'll, they'll, they'll, they're they'll side. They never really disliked slavery that much. They'll probably vote for us. Anyway, there's Republicans win, a clean sweep. Among the white southerners, there was this sense of terrible shock. They can't believe that their African-American neighbors have voted against them.
现在，在这一点上，他们还没有真正开始殴打人。田纳西州在那个八月有选举，但它们相当安静。现在，这是为什么呢？实际上是因为当地的那些前南方邦联分子正在疯狂地希望，这表明他们已经多么内化了自己的言论。他们希望他们的前奴隶会和他们的主人一起投票。他们对自己说，好吧，他们知道什么对他们最好。他们会，他们会，他们会，他们会站在我们这边。他们从来没有真正那么讨厌奴隶制。他们可能会投票给我们。无论如何，共和党人赢了，大获全胜。在南方白人中，有一种可怕的震惊感。他们无法相信他们的非裔美国邻居竟然投票反对他们。
And late that summer, Captain Judd of the Freedmen's Bureau reports on the clan for the first time, and he writes, this society is very numerous and it seems to extend all over the country, meaning the county. They march about the streets thoroughly disguised in a uniform. I'm credibly informed that they are heavily armed. I am sure they're capable of great mischief if they undertake it. The best citizens here say this Ku Klux Klan is got up by the young men merely for fun, and they never intend to interfere with anyone. This may well be true, but I doubt it mightily.
那年夏末，自由民局的贾德上尉第一次报告了三K党，他写道，这个协会非常庞大，似乎延伸到整个国家，指的是县。他们穿着统一的伪装在街上游行。我确实被告知他们装备精良。我相信如果他们采取行动，他们有能力造成巨大的破坏。这里最好的公民说，这个三K党只是年轻人为了好玩而搞出来的，他们从不打算干涉任何人。这可能是真的，但我非常怀疑。
The clan is poised to expand now from a few counties in central Tennessee. It is then going to burst out of Tennessee to every state in the former Confederacy. And for all its talk of honour and chivalry, the Ku Klux Klan is about to unleash. a reign of terror. Well, on that chilling note, let's take a break. This episode is brought to you by the Folio Society
三K党现在准备从田纳西州中部的几个县扩张。它随后将冲出田纳西州，进入前南方邦联的每一个州。尽管它谈论荣誉和骑士精神，但三K党即将释放一场恐怖统治。好吧，带着这个令人不寒而栗的音符，让我们休息一下。本集由Folio Society赞助播出。
and it's Tabby and Dominic here from the book club, Gollhanger's latest show. Now Tabby, as you know, there are some books that you read once, but there are others you especially return to again and again. And those second kind of books,
我是来自读书俱乐部的塔比和多米尼克，这是Gollhanger最新的节目。现在塔比，如你所知，有些书你读一次就够了，但有些书你特别会一遍又一遍地重读。而第二种书，
they really deserve to last, don't they? That's what the Folio Society does. They are an independent, employee-owned publisher based in London. Every book is produced with specially commissioned, beautiful artwork and a specially commissioned introduction that puts the story in its context. Folio Society publishes the books we love,
它们确实值得流传，不是吗？这就是Folio Society所做的。他们是一家位于伦敦的独立、员工持股的出版商。每一本书的制作都配有特别委托的精美艺术品和特别委托的导言，将故事置于其背景中。Folio Society出版我们喜爱的书籍，
from Bronte to Dickens, from Margaret Atwood to Tom Holland. The books can feel like works of art in their own right. They're built around the text, the stories that last in books that are made to last. If a story matters, keep it properly. Find it at foliosociety.com slash the book club. That's foliosociety.com slash the book club.
从勃朗特到狄更斯，从玛格丽特·阿特伍德到汤姆·霍兰德。这些书本身就像艺术品一样。它们围绕着文本构建，那些经久不衰的故事，以及那些为长久保存而制作的书籍。如果一个故事很重要，就好好保存它。在foliosociety.com/thebookclub找到它。那是foliosociety.com/thebookclub。
Getting ready for a game means being ready for anything. Like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember 988, Canada's suicide crisis helpline. It's good to know just in case. Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder any time. 988 suicide crisis helpline is funded by the government in Canada. This episode is brought to you by Claude by Anthropic.
为比赛做准备意味着为任何事情做好准备。比如带一根备用球杆。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我记住了988，加拿大的自杀危机求助热线。以防万一，知道这个很好。任何人都可以随时拨打或发短信，从训练有素的接线员那里获得免费的保密支持。988自杀危机求助热线由加拿大政府资助。本集由Anthropic的Claude赞助播出。
Now Tom, you and I, when we're together, we always argue about one thing, don't we? It's the existence or otherwise of the lockness monster. But you, foolishly, are sceptical and you don't think that there is a monster beneath the freezing waters of that Scottish lock. Because, as I know from AI, a plesiasaur would not be able to survive in Scottish waters because they'd just be too cold for it. Well, Tom, this back and forth is what makes studying history so fun, and actually Claude was made for this kind of thinking.
现在汤姆，你和我，当我们在一起时，我们总是争论一件事，不是吗？那就是尼斯湖水怪是否存在。但你愚蠢地持怀疑态度，你不认为在那苏格兰湖冰冷的水下有怪物。因为，正如我从人工智能那里了解到的，蛇颈龙无法在苏格兰水域生存，因为它们对它来说太冷了。好吧，汤姆，这种来回的争论正是学习历史的乐趣所在，事实上，Claude就是为这种思考而生的。
The deep research feature can pull from dozens of sources at once. It can surface contradictions between them, and it can give you a full breakdown with citations so that you can trace the evidence yourself. It's like having a research partner who's read literally everything and wants to chat about what it actually means. So very like Dominic, actually. Try Claude for free.
深度研究功能可以同时从几十个来源中提取信息。它可以揭示它们之间的矛盾，并可以为你提供带有引用的完整细分，以便你可以自己追踪证据。这就像有一个研究伙伴，他读过字面上的所有东西，并想聊聊它实际上意味着什么。所以实际上非常像多米尼克。免费试用Claude。
at clod.a.ai slash rest is history The Ku Klux Klan are called upon to castigate or kill any coloured cusses who may approve the constitution being concocted by the contemptible carpetbaggers at the cabadol. Each clan is commanded by a carnivorous kern who collects his comrades with care and caution commensurate with the magnitude of the cause.
在clod.a.ai/restishistory。三K党被要求惩罚或杀死任何可能赞同由国会大厦里那些可鄙的“地毯包客”所炮制的宪法的有色人种。每个三K党分部都由一个贪婪的“克恩”指挥，他以与事业规模相称的谨慎和小心召集他的同志。
Whenever convened they must correctly give four counter signs. These are kill the colored cuss, clean out the carpet baggers, crush the convention, carry conservatism, confusion to Congress, Confederates will conquer. So that is an insane article in a Virginia newspaper, the Richmond Dispatch in the spring of 1868. And what I could not adequately convey was that the degree to which
无论何时召集，他们必须正确给出四个暗号。这些是：杀死有色人种，清理地毯包客，粉碎大会，坚持保守主义，让国会困惑，邦联必胜。所以那是1868年春天弗吉尼亚州一份报纸《里士满快报》上的一篇疯狂的文章。而我无法充分传达的是，在报纸那一部分的打印件中，所有以C开头的单词在常规拼写中都被换成了K。是的，所以我们现在已经过了几个月了，我们从1866年走向1868年，而那是来自你说的弗吉尼亚州，汤姆，所以我们已经走出了田纳西州，正如一些报纸所称的“三K病毒”已经传播到了其原始州的边界之外。
all the words which begin with C in conventional spelling, they are given K's in the printout of that section from the newspaper. Yeah, so we've moved on a few months now, sort of we were in 1866 moving towards 1868 and that is from you said it was from Virginia Tom so we've moved outside Tennessee the Ku Klux virus as some papers called it has spread beyond the borders of its original state
正如那篇文章所显示的，它实际上比18个月前更加公开地种族主义和暴力。现在，这很大程度上归因于背景一直在变化。所以我在第一集中提到，在1866年和1867年，华盛顿的安德鲁·约翰逊总统（林肯在田纳西州的继任者）与国会中所谓的激进共和党人之间存在权力斗争。而国会赢了。
and as that article shows actually it is much more overtly racist and violent even now than it was 18 months or so ago now a lot of this is down to the fact the context is changing all the time so I mentioned in the first episode In 1866 and 1867, there was a power struggle in Washington between President Andrew Johnson, Lincoln's successor from Tennessee, and the so-called radical Republicans in Congress. And Congress won it.
所以首先，国会确保了第14修正案的通过。因此，第14修正案将美国公民身份扩展到任何在美国出生的人，包括前奴隶。他们现在是美国公民。第14修正案规定，任何州不得未经正当法律程序剥夺任何人的生命、自由或财产。那个正当法律程序，我的意思是，过去一个半世纪里，太多的宪法争论都归结为这些词，以及你可以和不可以对某人做什么。这就是成文宪法的问题，不是吗？疯了。
So first of all, Congress secured the passage of the 14th Amendment. So the 14th Amendment extends American citizenship to anybody born in the United States, including former slaves. They are now American citizens. The 14th Amendment mandates that no state can deprive any person of life, liberty or property without due process of law. That due process of law, I mean, so much constitutional argument in the last kind of century and a half has come down to those words and what you can and cannot do to somebody. That's the problem with the written constitution, isn't it? Bonkers.
我并不比你更同意它。而且第14修正案还保证所有公民在法律面前享有平等保护。同样，这意味着什么将在未来几年受到激烈争论。激进共和党人试图除掉约翰逊总统。他们弹劾了他，而他仅以一票之差在参议院幸存下来。所以他有点在苦苦支撑。但他们现在拥有所有的势头和所有的权力。在1867年春季到1868年初之间，他们走得更远，
I don't agree with it any more than you do. And the 14th Amendment also guarantees all citizens equal protection under the law. Again, what that means will be hotly contested in the years to come. The radical Republicans tried to get rid of President Johnson. They impeached him, and he survived by just one vote in the Senate. So he's kind of clinging on. But they have all the momentum now and all the power. Between spring 1867 and early 1868, they went further,
他们通过了四项重建法案，这些法案不仅远远超出了约翰逊对南方的计划，而且几乎可以肯定超出了亚伯拉罕·林肯在1865年去世时为南方计划的内容。所以现在，1867-68年，整个前南方邦联，除了已经重新加入联邦的田纳西州，整个前南方邦联都被置于军事管制之下，由美国陆军管理，选举将在军事监督下举行，以便黑人男性可以在其中投票。所以换句话说，他们基本上是在说，距离战争结束已经两年半了。南方已经证明自己无法表现良好。
and they passed four Reconstruction Acts that went way beyond, not just Johnson's plans for the South, but almost certainly what Abraham Lincoln was planning for the South when he died in 1865. So now, 186768, the entire former Confederacy, except for Tennessee, which has been readmitted to the Union, the entire former Confederacy is put under martial law and governed by the United States Army, and elections will be held under military supervision so that black men can vote in them. So in other words, they're basically saying it's two and a half years since the end of the war. The South has proved incapable of behaving itself.
我们正在重新实施军事管制。现在，如果你是一个前奴隶，这非常令人兴奋，因为现在你看起来有了一个保证，如果你是一个男人，你将能够行使你作为美国公民的权利并投下你的选票。因此，自由民们争先恐后地加入像这些联邦联盟和当地共和党组织之类的地方，因为他们觉得，太棒了，我们可以投票，没有人能阻止我们。所以当南方各州在1868年上半年举行选举时，结果非常强烈地偏向共和党，对吧，林肯的老党，解放的党。是的，当然。这意味着在接下来的两年里，南方大部分地区将处于共和党统治之下。
We are reimposing martial law. Now, this is very exciting if you're a former slave, because now you have what looks like a guarantee that you will be able to exercise your rights as an American citizen if you're a man and cast your vote. And so there's a great rush to enroll in things like these union leagues and local Republican organizations on the part of the. the freedmen because they're like, brilliant, we can vote and nobody will stop us. So when the southern states hold elections in the first half of 1868, the results very heavily favour the Republican Party, right, Leigham-Lincoln's old party, the party of emancipation. Yeah, of course. And so that means that for the next two years, much of the South will be under Republican rule.
如果你是一个支持南方邦联的南方白人，这对你来说绝对是一场噩梦。他们毫不掩饰自己想要扭转并摧毁这一切的愿望。正如一家民主党报纸所言，这些宪法和政府将持续存在，只要那些将它们引入存在的刺刀保持它们的存在，一天也不会多。换句话说，南方白人说，当然你们赢了这个，你知道，你们赢了战斗，但我们会击败你们。我们会扭转这一切，撤销所有这些。并恢复我们以前的至高无上地位。通过宪法以外的手段。
And if you're a white southerner who supported the Confederacy, this is an absolute nightmare for you. And they made no secret of their desire that they would roll this back and destroy it. As one Democrat newspaper put it, these constitutions and governments will last just as long as the bayonets which ushered them into being shall keep them in existence and not one day longer. In other words, the white Southerners say, sure you've won this, you know, you won the battle, but we will defeat you. We will roll this back and undo all this. And reggae. in our former supremacy. By extra constitutional means.
如果有必要，对吧？而且他们认为他们是，我的意思是，别忘了，他们认为他们是在捍卫他们的宪法自由和宪法特权等等。他们会说，好吧，你知道，如果我们有时必须使用宪法以外的手段来捍卫宪法，那就这样吧。他们会这么说。
If necessary, right? And they think they are, I mean, they think, don't forget, that they are fighting in defense of their constitutional liberties and their constitutional privileges and whatnot. And they would say, well, you know, if we have to sometimes use extra constitutional means to defend the constitution, then so be it. That's what they would say.
而且他们最主要有两个武器，对吧？第一个武器很简单，就是时间。所以如果你是一个白人民主党人，一个白人前邦联分子，你对自己说，我永远不会放弃。这对我来说绝对是生存问题。这是我生活方式、我的自我意识以及我活在世上的原因的核心。所以这对他们来说比对联邦主义者更重要。当然，如果你住在康涅狄格州或俄亥俄州什么的，最终你并不真正关心佐治亚州或密西西比州正在发生什么。所以随着时间的推移，你会失去兴趣。你会考虑你的铁路投资和其他此类
And they have two weapons above all, right? The first weapon is very simply time. So if you're a white Democrat, a white ex-confederate, a white ex-Confederate, you say to yourself, I will never give up. This is absolutely existential for me. This is central to my way of life and my sense of myself and the reason I'm on earth. So it matters more to them than it does to the unionists. Of course, if you live in Connecticut or Ohio or whatever, ultimately you don't really care what's going on in Georgia or in Mississippi. So over time, you will lose interest. You'll be thinking about your railroad investments and other such
镀金时代的事情。但如果你是一个南方人，你永远不会停止思考这个问题。他们拥有的第二个武器是暴力。这将从三个层面发挥作用。首先，暴力恐吓非裔美国人远离投票站。其次，暴力破坏和摧毁当地的共和党组织。最后，我认为在很多方面是关键的一点，你越暴力，就越能说服北方的人放弃。因为北方的人只会说，得了吧，我们永远无法改变南方。那是一个泥潭。但你知道人们是怎么想的。人们总是那样想。他们不，他们通常不会加倍努力说，好吧，我们会派遣更多军队。他们实际上说，天哪，真是个烂摊子和噩梦。让我们就这样
gilded age things. But if you're a southerner, you will never stop thinking about this. And the second weapon they have is violence. And that will work on three levels. First of all, violence to intimidate African Americans away from the polls. Secondly, violence to disrupt and destroy local republican organizations. And finally, and I think in many ways the key thing, the more violent you are, the more it will persuade people in the north to give up. Because people in the north will just say, come on, we're never going to change the South. It's a morass. But you know how people think like that. People always think like that. They don't, they often don't double down and say, well, we'll send more troops. They actually say, God, what a mess and a nightmare. Let's just
结束吧。把我们的手从这个魔幻的混合物中拿出来。所以这就是三K党扩张的背景。是的，它最初可能只是打扮、为了好玩、作为一个社交俱乐部、给女孩唱小夜曲等等。但到了这一点，它已经更多地成为一种准军事团体协会，致力于以白人至上主义的名义推翻共和党统治。其实它不是唯一的一个。所以还有其他的。有一个叫“白人兄弟会”的组织。北卡罗来纳州有一个叫“隐形帝国”的组织。
call it a day. Take our hand out of the magic mix. So this is the background for the expansion of the clan. Yes, it started as possibly as dressing up, as having fun, as a social club, serenading girls, whatever. But by this point, it has become much more a sort of association of paramilitary groups that are dedicated to overthrowing Republican rule in the name of white supremacy. It's not the only one, actually. So there are others. There's a group called the White Brotherhood. There's a group called the Invisible Empire in North Carolina.
最著名的一个，我的意思是，你在前半部分谈到了沃尔特·斯科特和关于骑士精神的那种东西。这在南方文化中非常普遍，因为最著名的竞争对手被称为“白山茶花骑士团”。那是在路易斯安那州成立的。他们听起来不太吓人。他们非常吓人。不，他们非常暴力。我的意思是，你不想站在白山茶花骑士团的对立面，我可以告诉你。他们成立于新奥尔良，这是一个在这一时期极其暴力的城市。
The most famous one, I mean, you were saying about Walter Scott in the first half and the sort of stuff about chivalry. That's so common in southern kind of culture, because the most famous rival is called the Knights of the White Chameleas. And that was set up in Louisiana. They don't sound very frightening. They're very frightening. No, they're terribly violent. I mean, you don't want to be on the wrong side of the knights of the white camellias, I can tell you. They were founded in New Orleans, an extremely violent city in this period.
1867年5月，他们有类似的仪式、握手和密码。他们在宪法中明确致力于，我引用，“白人种族的至高无上”。是的，好吧，他们很吓人。但在所有这些组织中，三K党扩张得最远。我认为部分原因是……内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特。他是一个非常好的代言人，尤其是因为他是塞尔玛、马里昂和孟菲斯铁路公司的总裁。所以他在铁路工作中经常在南方旅行，特别是在密西西比州和阿拉巴马州。他也是一个人寿保险
In May 1867, they had similar rituals and handshakes and passwords. And they were explicitly devoted in their constitution to, and I quote, the supremacy of the white race. Yeah, okay, they are frightening. But of all of them, it's the clan that expands the furthest. Part of this, I think, is because of the... Nathan Bedford Forrest. He's a really good frontman for it, not least because he's the president of the Selma, Marion and Memphis Railroad. So he's traveling a lot across the South in his railroad duties, especially Mississippi and Alabama. He's also going, he's also a life insurance
推销员。所以他有点在旅行，向寡妇什么的推销人寿保险。每当他在那里时，他都会见当地的大人物，他会见其他南方邦联退伍军人，像他一样不喜欢南方发生的事情的其他军官，在他离开后，他们会建立其他准军事团体，像三K党一样，保卫南方免受激进重建的恐怖。而且这些，我印象中，很多最终成为南方三K党大龙和泰坦的人，都是内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特以前的酒友、战友什么的，他在人寿保险工作中拜访过他们，然后激励他们建立了自己的三K党。
salesman. So he's kind of traveling to sell life insurance to widows or whatever. And whenever he's there, he will meet local bigwigs and he'll meet other Confederate events. veterans, other officers like him who don't like what's happened to the South, and they will set up after he's left other paramilitary groups like the Klan to defend the South against the horrors of radical reconstruction. And these, I think I get the impression that a lot of the people who end up becoming grand dragons and grand titans of the Southern clan are ex kind of drinking buddies, war comrades and whatnot of Nathan Bedford Forrest, who he's visited in his life insurance duties and then inspired them to set up their own clans.
你认为他把头衔和人寿保险捆绑在一起了吗？买一份，你就可以成为一个大侏儒。对，完全正确。但实际上，我认为传播三K党最大的影响实际上只是报纸，南方民主党报纸。所以到1868年，他们定期报道三K党在田纳西州的活动。他们基本上是在说，你知道，在田纳西州，有一个叫三K党的组织，为他们欢呼。
Do you think he bundles in a title with the life insurance? Take it out and you can be a grand gnome. Right, exactly. But actually, I think the biggest influence in spreading the clan is actually just the newspapers, Southern Democratic newspapers. So they are regularly reporting by 1868, the clan's activities in Tennessee. And they're basically saying, you know, in Tennessee, there's this group called the clan and hurrah for them.
他们正在反击共和党强加的暴虐的黑人统治。所以这是1868年3月的弗吉尼亚州《里士满问询报和审查报》。它说，三K党面具背后的目的是坚定、高尚和英勇的，就像布鲁图斯在他那伪装的愚蠢面具下所隐藏的那样。这对布鲁图斯公平吗？布鲁图斯回到节目中真是太好了，不是吗？因为他非常受布斯的钦佩，他是罗马共和党人的领袖，他们赶走了君主制。这是第一个布鲁图斯，那个领导
they are fighting back against the tyrannical imposition of black rule by the Republican Party. So this is the Richmond, Virginia, Inquirer and Examiner in March 1868. It said that the clan was behind its mask was a purpose as resolute, noble and heroic as that which Brutus concealed beneath his mask of well-dissembled idiocy. Is that fair to Brutus? It's great to have Brutus back on the show, isn't it? Because he was much admired by Booth, and he is the leader of the Roman-reiber. Republicans who threw out the monarchy. This is the first Brutus, the Brutus who leads the
反抗君主制的叛乱的布鲁图斯。哦，反抗傲慢的塔克文。因为他伪装成一个白痴。所以我认为这就是那里发生的事情。所以他们打扮成荒谬的服装，他们是在掩盖他们秘密地是冷酷杀手的事实。是的。有趣的是，他们不认为自己是阴谋者。他们认为阴谋是别人的。因为正如这份里士满报纸所说，这个阴谋是一个秘密的黑人阴谋，其目的是建立黑人统治。顺便说一句，这就是他们一直使用的那种语言。所以有两个明显的问题。
rebellion against the monarchy. Oh, against talking the proud. Because he disguised himself as an idiot. So I think that's what's going on there. So the idea that they're dressing up in kind of ludicrous costumes, they're disguising the fact that secretly they're ruthless killers. Yes. And the funny thing is that they don't think they're the conspirators. They think the conspiracy is somebody else. Because as this Richmond newspaper says, the conspiracy is a secret Negro conspiracy which has for its object the establishment of Negro domination. This is the kind of language they use all the time, by the way. So two obvious questions.
什么样的人加入它，在哪里？首先，三K党在共和党人很多的地方并不兴旺。原因很明显。例如，如果这是一个在内战中支持联邦的地方，在阿巴拉契亚山脉，在没有种植园的山区，永远不会有很多人加入三K党。没有足够的南方邦联分子。人们也不会在他们被非裔美国人、自由民大量超过的地方建立三K党。
What kind of people join it and where? So first of all, the clan does not thrive in places where there are lots and lots of Republicans. For obvious reasons. If it's a place that backed the Union in the Civil War, for example, in the Appalachians, in the mountains where there are no plantations, there are never going to be many people to join the clan. There just aren't enough Confederates. also people aren't going to set up a clan somewhere where they are massively outnumbered by African Americans, by freedmen.
所以，在密西西比三角洲，黑人人数是白人的三倍。你在那里建立三K党会很疯狂，因为真的，你知道，你会挨揍，你会站在那场战斗的错误一边。基本上，三K党最终建立在黑人和白人人口大致相等，或者白人略少的地方。他们可以这样做，因为白人可以随时获得武器，而黑人则不能。白人，总的来说，他们可以获得武器和更好的武器。
So in the Mississippi Delta, in the Mississippi Delta, black people outnumber white by three to one. You'd be mad to set up the clan there because really, you know, you'd get beaten up, you'd be on the wrong side of that fight. Basically, the clan ends up being set up where black and white populations are roughly equal or where whites are slightly outnumbered. And they can do that because the whites have ready access to weapons and the Blackstone. The whites, by and large, they have access to weapons and better weapons.
他们更富有。他们更强大。他们联系更紧密。他们有更多的资源。你知道，所有这些事情。我想他们也控制了法律体系。是的，当然。警长、法官，所有这些事情。
They are richer. They are more powerful. They are better connected. They have more resources. You know, all of those kinds of things. And I suppose also they have control of the legal system. Yes, of course. Sheriffs, judges, all of those kinds of things.
他们掌握着所有的权力杠杆。因为所有这些在某种程度上已经改变了，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的变化，那就是曾经想要奴隶的人不再是奴隶了。他们仍然住在土地上。他们仍然住在那种木屋、棚屋之类的地方。土地没有被重新分配。他们没有被给予，最初的承诺是大约三英亩土地和一头骡子之类的，他们会被给予。他们从来没有得到过。
They have all the leaves of power. Because all that has changed, to some degree, I mean, it's a massive change, is that people who will want slaves are no longer slaves. They're still living on the land. They're still living in kind of wooden cabins, shacks and things. The land has not been redistributed. They have not been given, the initial promise was something like three acres and a mule or something that they would be given. They never were given them.
他们仍然非常无力。所以，当然，如果发生冲突，他们总是处于巨大的劣势。法律体系以及武器可以被用来恐吓他们。是的，确实会这样，完全正确。现在，至于加入三K党的人，可能大多数是普通的农民和劳工，但有很多关于律师、医生之类的人加入的记录。
They are still very powerless. So, of course, if there's a conflict, they will always be at a massive disadvantage. And the legal system, as well as weaponry, can be used to terrorise them. Yes, which it will be, exactly. Now, as for the kind of people who join the clan, probably the majority of very ordinary kind of farmers and labourers, but there are lots of accounts of lawyers and doctors and whatnot, professional people joining.
正如艾伦·特雷利斯在他关于三K党的精彩著作中所说，问题在于，南方白人的所有阶层都曾参与奴隶制，他们一直以来，所有阶层都曾共同努力捍卫它，所有阶层在内战期间都在南方邦联军队中服役。不过，我认为你关于“好玩”的观点很重要。所以有一个叫查尔斯·斯特恩斯的共和党种植园主，他住在佐治亚州。他是一个反常的人物，因为我说过他是一个种植园主，但他是一个共和党人。他讨厌三K党。
As Alan Treleis says in his brilliant book on the clan, the thing is, all classes of the White South had been complicit in slavery, and they had always, all classes had worked together to defend it, and all classes had served in the Confederate Army during the Civil War. I think your point about fun, though, is an important one. So there's a Republican plantation owner called Charles Stearns, who lived in Georgia. He's an anomalous figure, because I said he was a plantation owner, but he's a Republican. And he hated the clan.
他后来谈到三K党时说，那是些既不比普通民众更好也不更坏的人，只是些有大量闲暇时间、灵魂中充满冒险精神、倾向于叛逆的年轻人。重复一遍。他不喜欢他们，但他说是些年轻人，他们喜欢战斗，喜欢冒险，喜欢打扮，喜欢，你知道，殴打人。我认为这绝对是其中的一部分。我的意思是，在一个被战争撕裂、实际上没什么别的事情可做的世界里，这种令人兴奋的元素，对我来说完全说得通。而驱动他们的是每个南方白人脑海深处的噩梦，
And he said of the clan later on, he said it was men who were neither better nor worse than the average of the population, but simply young men with plenty of leisure on their hands, with a great love of adventure in their souls and intensely rebel in their proclivities. repeat. He didn't like them, but he said they're kind of, they're young men who like fighting, who like adventure, who like dressing up, who like, you know, beating people up. I think that's definitely part of it. I mean, that element of it being exciting in a world that has been ripped apart by war, and which is nothing really much else to do, I mean, that makes complete sense to me. And what drives them is the nightmare that's the back of every white
那就是他们将被他们曾经视为财产的人所统治。所以加入三K党是什么感觉？显然，有打扮的兴奋感。通常他们不需要穿伪装，因为，正如你所说，他们控制着法律体系。我认为那部分，他们通常真的是为了好玩。他们不只是穿白色。
Southerner's mind, which is the fact that they will be ruled by people they'd once regarded as their property. So what's it like to be in the clan? Obviously, there's the excitement of dressing up. Often they don't need to wear the disguises, because, as you say, they control the legal system. That part of it, I think they're often, they really are doing it for fun. They don't just wear white.
他们晚上穿黑色。他们穿红色。有些分部穿黄色。我的意思是，他们骑着马穿着那种黄色的长袍什么的，看起来一定很奇怪。哦，对。好像如果那些长袍是白色的，他们看起来就不奇怪一样。好吧，我想我们已经习惯了他们穿白色长袍的想法，对吧？我的意思是，如果有人拍了一部电影，其中三K党骑着马穿着红色和黄色的长袍，你会觉得那很奇怪，不是吗？
They wear black and night. They wear red. Some clans wear yellow. I mean, they must look very weird, riding around in their kind of yellow robes or whatever. Oh, right. Like they don't look weird if those robes are white. Well, I guess we're used to the idea of them being white roads, right? I mean, if somebody makes a film in which the Ku Klux Klan are riding around in red and yellow robes, you'd find that very, would you not find that a bit odd?
大香蕉。完全正确。好吧，他们并不总是戴那些帽子。所以有时他们会戴角或胡子，或者他们有巨大的舌头，带有巨大舌头的面具。而且重要的点是，实际上，他们的长袍通常是由他们的妻子、姐妹或母亲之类的制作的。所以女性也参与了三K党。但她们在其中没有正式的角色。不。
The grand banana. Exactly. Well, they don't always wear those hats. So sometimes they will wear horns or beards or they have giant tongues, masks with massive tongues. And important points, actually, their robes were generally made by their wives or their sisters or their mothers or whatever. So women are involved in the clan as well. But they don't have official roles within it. No.
没有那种大妖婆之类的。下周在第二个三K党中，我们将谈论很多三K党女性，但在这个三K党中没有。他们通过这些疯狂的通知招募成员。你在最开始读了一个。很多关于鬼魂、墓地和某种“坟墓时刻已经到来”之类的东西。所有这些事情。同样，我的意思是，这里有一个很好的例子，实际上。这是为你准备的。
There isn't a kind of the grand gobliness or anything. In the second clan next week, we'll be talking about a lot of clans women, but not in this clan. And they recruit members through these mad notices. You read one right at the beginning. Lots of stuff about ghosts and graveyards and kind of the hour of the sepulchre has come or whatever. All of that kind of thing. Again, I mean, there's a good example here, actually. This is made for you.
你一生都在为这一刻做准备，你可以从《塔斯卡卢萨阿拉巴马独立观察家报》上读一段。准备好，准备好，准备好。地狱中南方邦联死者的强大地精们，集合。复仇，复仇，复仇。要保密。要谨慎。要可怕。
All your life you've been building towards the moment when you could do a reading from the Tuscaloosa Alabama independent monitor. Make ready, make ready, make ready. The mighty hobgoblins of the Confederate dead in hell, a blue assemble. Revenge, revenge, revenge. Be secret. Be cautious. Be terrible.
经特别批准，地狱为你结冰。冒犯的鬼魂。穿上你的溜冰鞋，跨越到大地母亲那里。就这样一直持续下去。那大约是十分之一的时间。它只是继续。这是胡言乱语。我的意思是，它甚至意味着什么？
By special grant, hell freezes over for your passage. Offended ghosts. Put on your skates and cross over to Mother Earth. And so it just goes on and on like that. That's like about a tenth of the time. It just goes on. And it's Babble. I mean, what does it even mean?
这是词语沙拉。穿上你的溜冰鞋，跨越到大地母亲那里。好吧，我想它是说地狱刚刚结冰了。哦，当然。是的，地狱结冰了。好吧。我太笨了，听不懂三K党的招募信息。实际上，三K党变成了一种疯狂的流行热潮，听起来很奇怪。
It's a word salad. Put on your skates and cross over to Mother Earth. Well, I suppose it said that hell has just freeze over. Oh, of course. Yeah, hell is phrased. Okay. I'm just too stupid to understand a Kugoslan recruiting message. And actually the clan becomes this kind of mad, popular craze, as weird as that sounds.
所以人们建立了三K党少年棒球队。有一首歌叫《三K党午夜点名》。还有三K党商品。所以你可以买刀。你可以买油漆。你可以买，这是最疯狂的一个，三K党吸烟烟草包
So people set up Koo Kluks junior baseball teams. There is a song called the Klu Klux Midnight Roll Call. And there is Koo Klux Murch. So you can buy knives. You can buy paint. you can buy, this is the maddest one, a Ku Klux smoking tobacco pack
其中包含100个忠实三K党人的灵魂，并附有伟大的大独眼巨人的准确且吸引人的全身肖像。所以这让整件事听起来像个笑话。而且仍然有一个你描述为“戏谑”的元素。所以他们从不烧十字架，第一个三K党，但他们确实对他们的黑人邻居玩奇怪的恶作剧。所以他们会穿上这些框架
that contains the spirits of 100 faithful KKKs with an accurate and attractive full-led portrait of the Great Grand Cyclops. So this makes the whole thing sound like a joke. And there is still an element that you describe it as japery. So they never burn crosses the clan, the first clan, but they do play weird, practical jokes on their black neighbours. So they will dress up in these sort of frames
让他们看起来像12英尺高的鬼魂，他们会恐吓自由民。他们会做一些事情，我的意思是，这听起来太疯狂了。他们会戴上可拆卸的手，强迫黑人在街上和他们握手，然后手会掉下来。或者他们最喜欢的把戏听起来太奇怪了。他们会把某种瓶子绑在胸前
that make them look like 12-foot tall ghostly figures and they'll intimidate the freedmen. They will do stuff like, I mean, this sounds so deranged. They will put on detachable hands and force black people to shake their hand in the street and then the hand will come off. Or their favourite trick just sounds so weird. they will strap a sort of bottle to their chest
在兜帽和长袍下面，他们会假装喝掉大量的液体。那是怎么运作的？因为基本上你是把它倒进你的……如果你在看视频，你可以看到我，我在模仿它。你把它倒进你的兜帽里，然后你有一个隐藏的……哦，我明白了。
underneath their hood and their robes and they will pretend to drink gigantic quantities of water. How does that work? Because basically you're pouring it into your... If you're watching on video, you can see me, I'm miming it. You're pouring into your hood and then you've got a kind of concealed... Oh, I see.
你有一个隐藏的瓶子。所以看起来你在喝掉惊人数量的水。如果你忘了这样做，那么难怪你的长袍是黄色的。对，非常好。现在，在20世纪初，同情南方邦联“迷失事业”的历史学家声称，这些把戏很聪明，它们恐吓了非裔美国人，阻止了他们投票，并帮助南方从重建的恐怖中解脱出来。但历史学家现在普遍认为，自由民被这些把戏所欺骗的想法本身就是一个种族主义神话。正如艾伦·特雷利斯所说，这实际上不是一个关于黑人迷信鬼魂的故事，这是一个关于白人对黑人迷信的故事，因为它基本上，三K党成员在玩这些把戏，大笑并对彼此说
You've got a concealed bottle. So it looks like you're drinking on an earthly quantity of water. And if you forget to do it, then no wonder your robes are yellow. Right, very good. Now, in the early 20th century, historians who were sympathetic to the lost cause of the Confederacy claimed that these tricks were brilliant and that they terrified African Americans and they stopped
天哪，非裔美国人太容易上当了，他们被我的可拆卸手骗了。实际上，当然，非裔美国人根本没有被骗，但他们只是害怕如果他们不配合游戏，如果他们不假装害怕，他们就会被私刑处死。
them voting and they helped redeem the South from the horrors of reconstruction. But historians now generally say the idea that the freedmen were taken in by these sort of tricks is itself a racist myth. As Alan Trellis says, this is actually a story not about black superstition about ghosts. it's a story about white superstitions about black people because it basically the white, the clansmen are playing these tricks and laughing and saying to them each other
是的，然后他们会被殴打或杀死什么的。我的意思是，遇到一个恶作剧者已经够糟糕了。但遇到一个如果你不笑他的笑话就会杀了你的恶作剧者。那是更糟的。完全正确。而且实际上，对这些残酷笑话的强调有点误导，因为到1868年夏天，三K党真正关心的就是暴力。
gosh, the African Americans are so gullible they're taken in by my detachable hand. In reality, of course, the African Americans aren't taken in by it at all but they're just terrified that if they don't play up the game and if they don't pretend to be frightened they'll be lynched.
所以这就是为什么三K党很重要。不是打扮，不是笑话，而是因为殴打、枪杀、绞刑、强奸和谋杀成千上万的人，其中绝大多数是黑人。像三K党本身一样，暴力真的在1868年田纳西州的县选举前夕开始了。其中一个记录最好的例子是一个叫莫里县的地方，它在纳什维尔以南，三K党在那里有几百名成员。他们会在晚上进行这些袭击。会有大约一打戴兜帽的人，他们会针对孤立的农村地区。
Yeah, then they'll be beaten up or killed or whatever. I mean, it's bad enough, meeting a practical joker. But meeting a practical joker will kill you if you don't laugh at his joke. That's the worst. Exactly right. And actually, the emphasis on these cruel jokes is a bit misleading because by the summer of 1868, what the clan is really about is violence.
是的，然后他们会被殴打、杀害或遭遇其他不幸。我的意思是，遇到一个恶作剧者已经够糟糕了。但遇到一个如果你不笑他的笑话就会杀了你的恶作剧者，那才是最糟糕的。完全正确。事实上，对这些残酷笑话的强调有点误导性，因为到1868年夏天，三K党真正关心的其实是暴力。
So this is why the clan matters. Not the dressing up, not the jokes, but because of the beating and shooting and hanging and rape and murder of thousands of people, the vast majority of them, black. Like the clan itself, the violence really. begins in earnest in Tennessee in 1868 in the build-up to the county elections. And one of the best documented examples is a place called Mori County, which was south of Nashville, and the clan had several hundred members there. And they would carry out these attacks at night. There'd be about a dozen hooded men, and they would target isolated rural
这就是三K党之所以重要的原因。不是因为装扮，也不是因为笑话，而是因为对成千上万人的殴打、枪杀、绞刑、强奸和谋杀，其中绝大多数是黑人。就像三K党本身一样，暴力实际上是在1868年田纳西州县选举前夕真正开始的。记录最详尽的例子之一是一个叫莫里县的地方，它在纳什维尔以南，三K党在那里有几百名成员。他们会在晚上发动这些袭击。大约会有十几名戴着头套的人，他们会针对偏远的农村地区。
homes, with black residents, they would target them. Sometimes they'd been accused of crimes, often because they were regarded as outspoken or insolent in the kind of language of the White South, because they were politically active, because they were planning to vote Republican, or sometimes there was no reason at all. The Klansman just wanted to attack a black family. They'd arrive outside your house, they would either call you out or they would drag you outside. The victims are usually men or older boys, but not always, so there are attacks on children or on pregnant women.
对于黑人居民的家，他们会将其作为目标。有时他们被指控犯罪，通常是因为在南方白人的话语体系中，他们被认为过于直言不讳或傲慢无礼，因为他们积极参与政治，因为他们计划投票给共和党，或者有时根本没有任何理由。三K党人只是想攻击一个黑人家庭。他们会到达你家门外，要么把你叫出来，要么把你拖到外面。受害者通常是男性或较大的男孩，但也不尽然，所以也有针对儿童或孕妇的袭击。
Often you'll be beaten with sticks hundreds of times on your bare back, but sometimes the attacks would go much further. So there's a story about one 20-year-old black man who was dragged from his home in Columbia, Tennessee, by a Klansman who garrotted him, and then they tied a stone round his neck, and they threw him into the river. There was another man called Henry Fitzpatrick. He'd been accused on the base of no evidence of setting fire to some barns. He was lashed 200 times one night, and then the next night the Klansman came back. and they hanged him. Then a third example, black veteran of the Union Army. So, I mean, he ticks every clan target box.
你经常会被棍棒在裸背上殴打数百次，但有时袭击会变本加厉。有一个故事讲的是一名20岁的黑人男子在田纳西州哥伦比亚市被三K党人从家中拖出，他们勒死了他，然后在他的脖子上系了一块石头，把他扔进了河里。还有一个人叫亨利·菲茨帕特里克。他被指控纵火焚烧了一些谷仓，但没有任何证据。一天晚上他被鞭打了200下，第二天晚上三K党人又回来了，他们绞死了他。第三个例子，一名联邦军队的黑人退伍军人。我的意思是，他符合三K党的所有攻击目标。
He's black and he had fought for the North in the Civil War. He's Clinton Drake and he is dragged from his house and hanged. And the Klansman then proclaimed a warning. They said, all Union veterans, you know, heed his example or you will face the same fate. And as time goes on, the clan becomes more and more public about all this. So in July 1868, there's a parade on the 4th of July actually in the town of Columbia. And Klansmen ended up fighting a pitched battle, about 150 Klansmen with 30 armed freedmen who had hidden their guns from the clan's regular sweeps. So that goes back to your question, Tom, about are the freedmen arming themselves?
他是黑人，曾在内战中为北方而战。他叫克林顿·德雷克，他被从家中拖出并绞死。三K党人随后发出了警告。他们说，所有的联邦退伍军人，你们要引以为戒，否则你们将面临同样的命运。随着时间的推移，三K党在这些事情上变得越来越公开。1868年7月，实际上是在7月4日，哥伦比亚镇举行了一场游行。三K党人最终与30名武装的自由民进行了一场激烈的战斗，这些自由民把枪藏起来躲过了三K党的常规搜查。这回到了你的问题，汤姆，关于自由民是否在武装自己？
Yes, some of the freedmen do have guns. The clan will search for them. These freedmen have hidden them. and they end up having basically a pitched battle. And the result of this is that it radicalises the white population of the county. They all basically pile in on behalf of the clan. And the black men flee, they flee into the countryside. And for the next few weeks, the clan are basically scaring the countryside for these guys.
是的，一些自由民确实有枪。三K党会搜查他们。这些自由民把枪藏了起来，最终他们基本上进行了一场激烈的战斗。其结果是，这激化了该县的白人人口。他们基本上都站在三K党一边。黑人逃跑了，他们逃进了乡村。在接下来的几周里，三K党基本上在乡村搜寻这些人。
When they find them, they lynch them. Some of them managed to escape to Nashville, but most of them didn't. And Dominic, are the other clan targeting black people who are literate? Yes, absolutely they are. We'll talk about this in the next episode, actually, about how the clan target black people who can read and write, black people who want to be teachers, people who are ministers, people are active in the community, basically anybody who challenges the idea that black people are inherently subordinate and inferior. Even if you do too well, if you're too good at farming, if you own your own livestock, they will come after you because you are challenging. the principles on which their kind of their sense of the world, I guess, is based. So it's like the Spartans and the Messenians or the Nazis with the Poles. If you're literate or if you are high-ranking, your toast.
当他们找到他们时，就会私刑处死他们。有些人设法逃到了纳什维尔，但大多数人没有。多米尼克，三K党是否也在针对识字的黑人？是的，绝对是。我们将在下一集讨论这个问题，关于三K党如何针对那些会读写、想成为教师、担任牧师、在社区中活跃的黑人，基本上针对任何挑战“黑人天生从属且低劣”这一观念的人。即使你表现得太好，如果你在耕种方面太出色，如果你拥有自己的牲畜，他们也会来找你，因为你在挑战他们世界观所基于的原则。所以这就像斯巴达人和美塞尼亚人，或者纳粹对待波兰人一样。如果你识字或者地位高，你就完了。
So the million-dollar question is why the authorities don't stop it. And the obvious answer is that it's just very, very difficult. You can't rely on local law enforcement because so many sheriffs and whatnot are sympathetic to the clan. And we know that basically in every case where black people try to go to the courts to get justice, They cannot get a sheriff to arrest, they can't get a grand jury to indict, they can't get attorneys to prosecute and they can't get jurors to convict. So all of this puts a lot of pressure on the governor of Tennessee, Parson Brownlow. He's in a real bind because his Republican legislature in Nashville is very anxious about alienating white opinion by sending in the state militia.
所以价值百万美元的问题是为什么当局不阻止它。显而易见的答案是这非常非常困难。你不能依赖当地的执法部门，因为太多的警长之类的人同情三K党。我们知道，基本上在每一个黑人试图通过法院寻求正义的案例中，他们都无法让警长逮捕人，无法让大陪审团起诉，无法让律师控告，也无法让陪审员定罪。所以这一切给田纳西州州长帕森·布朗洛带来了巨大的压力。他陷入了真正的困境，因为他在纳什维尔的共和党立法机构非常担心通过派遣州民兵来疏远白人的舆论。
Because if they send in the state militia, that means basically arming a lot of. African-American volunteers, which is the one thing that's guaranteed. Well, I mean, but you might say, so what? I mean, I think you could reasonably say, so what? I mean, I think a lot of radical Republicans would say, come on, what are you going to lose? The clan and the white and the white supremacists are in arms already. I mean, they're not going to vote Republican, so it doesn't really matter. Right, exactly.
因为如果他们派遣州民兵，那基本上意味着要武装许多非裔美国志愿者，这是唯一能保证的事情。好吧，我的意思是，你可能会说，那又怎样？我想你可以合理地说，那又怎样？我想很多激进的共和党人会说，得了吧，你会失去什么？三K党和白人至上主义者已经武装起来了。我的意思是，他们无论如何都不会投票给共和党，所以这真的没关系。对，没错。
At first, his instinct is to send for federal troops. So he sends for federal troops. There's an infantry company of the U.S. Army sent to clans. Columbia, Tennessee, but they are totally useless because Washington is telling them work with the local authorities, and the local authorities are, of course, on the side of the clan. So by the summer of 1868, law and order in Middle Tennessee is very close to breaking down. And the Freemans Bureau reports to Washington, and I quote, The Colored People are leaving their homes and are fleeing to the towns and large cities
起初，他的直觉是请求联邦军队。所以他请求了联邦军队。美国陆军的一个步兵连被派往田纳西州哥伦比亚的三K党地区，但他们完全没用，因为华盛顿告诉他们要与当地当局合作，而当地当局当然是站在三K党一边的。因此，到1868年夏天，田纳西州中部的法律和秩序已濒临崩溃。自由民局向华盛顿报告说，我引用一下：“有色人种正在离开家园，逃往城镇和大城市寻求保护，如果那里不立即采取行动，城市将被贫穷、无助的人群淹没。三K党组织如此庞大且武装精良，任何人都无法对他们施加任何道德影响。火药和子弹是唯一能镇压他们的东西。”布朗洛本人终于失去了耐心。他召集了州立法机构的特别会议，他说，看，我们已经给了他们每一个机会。但没有一个人受到惩罚。他们逍遥法外地犯下了数千起罪行。所以他们通过了一项法案，规定为了扰乱治安而加入秘密组织是非法的。
for protection, and there something has done immediately, the cities will be flooded by poor, helpless creatures. The Ku Klux organization is so extensive and so well organized in arms that it's beyond the power of anyone to exert any moral influence over them. Powder and ball is the only thing that will put them down. And Brownow himself has finally run out of patience. He calls for a special session of the state legislature and he says, look, you know, we've given them every chance. And not one of them has been punished. They've carried out thousands of crimes with impunity. So they pass a bill that makes it illegal to join a secret organization for the purpose of disturbing the peace
他们授权布朗洛向任何县派遣州民兵，只要有10个人，你需要10个人说法律没有得到执行，然后你就可以派遣州民兵。而这些人可以是黑人。是的，完全正确。所以这现在成了田纳西州中部白人的巨大噩梦，艾伦·特里利斯称之为终极恐怖，即他们的城镇将由拿着枪的黑人巡逻，他们将为多年的奴隶制进行报复。实际上有趣的是，他们退缩了。是那些白人至上主义的前邦联军人崩溃了，因为内森·贝德福德·福雷斯特和乔治·戈登带领他们所有的伙伴去纳什维尔见州长，他们说，好吧，我们收手了。
and they authorise Browno to send in the state militia to any county where 10 people, you need 10 people to say the law is not being enforced and then you can send in the state militia. And those people can be black. Yes, exactly. So this is now the great nightmare for the white people of Middle Tennessee. what Alan Trillies calls the ultimate horror that their towns are going to be patrolled
不会再有暴力事件了。他们公开承诺将帮助当局维护州的和平与秩序。实际上，戈登将军在三K党的发源地普拉斯基举行了一次集会。他说，未来我们应该遵守法律，维护和平与和谐的精神。实际上，起初这似乎奏效了。
by black men with guns who are going to get revenge for all the years of slavery. And actually the funny thing is they blink. It's their white supremacist ex-Confederates who crack because Nathan Bedford Forrest and George Gordon lead all their mates to go to Nashville and to see the governor and they say, fine, we'll call off the dogs, as it were.
所以紧张局势似乎消散了，布朗洛的强硬路线确实得到了回报。然而，在邦联的其他州，这段时间以来，对三K党的支持一直在增加。所以三K党现在在原邦联南部的所有县中，可能有四分之一拥有据点，成员可能达到约15万人。
There'll be no more violence. And they make a public promise that they will help the authorities maintain the peace and order of the state. And actually, Gordon, General Gordon, gives a rally in Pulaski, the homeland of the clan. And he says, in future, we should obey the laws and uphold a spirit of peace and harmony. And actually, at first, it seems to work.
别忘了，此时我们正处于1868年的夏天，现在赌注变得非常高。提醒一下，共和国的未来在过去一年左右的时间里一直掌握在国会的激进共和党人手中，除了田纳西州以外，整个邦联都处于军事占领之下。但在1868年11月3日，美国人民将有机会扭转局面。
So it seems that the tension dissipates and actually Brownlow's hard line has paid off. However, in the other states of the Confederacy, all this time, clan support has been building. So the clan is now heading towards having dens in perhaps a quarter of all counties in the former Confederate South and probably about 150,000 members.
因为这将是内战以来的第一次总统选举。所以共和党人选择了尤利西斯·S·格兰特将军作为他们的候选人。他是终极的北方战争英雄，他将站在一个明确的为所有人提供平等和公民政治权利的纲领上。但民主党人选择了纽约州州长霍拉肖·西摩作为他们的候选人，他是激进重建的直言不讳的批评者。他的竞选口号是，我引用一下：“这是白人的国家，让白人统治。”
And don't forget, we're in the summer of 1868 at this point. and now the stakes are becoming very high. A reminder, the future of the Republic for the last year or so has been in the hands of the radical Republicans in Congress and the whole Confederacy, with exception of Tennessee, has been under military occupation. But on the 3rd of November 1868, the American people will have a chance to turn back the clock
令人不寒而栗，多米尼克，未来将会更加令人不寒而栗。历史俱乐部其余部分的成员当然可以立即听到关于南方未来的斗争以及三K党第一化身的命运。
because this will be the first presidential election since the Civil War. So the Republicans as their candidate have chosen General Ulysses S. Grant. So he is the ultimate northern war hero, and he is going to stand on an explicit platform of equal and civil political rights for all. But the Democrats have chosen as their candidate, Governor Horatio Seymour of New York, and he is an outspoken critic of radical reconstruction. And his campaign slogan is, and I quote, this is a white man's country
如果你是历史俱乐部其余部分的成员，你还可以听到接下来的两集，也就是第三集和第四集，它们将故事带入了20世纪。所以，如果你还不是会员，你知道该怎么做。访问Restishistory.com并注册。谢谢你，多米尼克。谢谢大家的收听。再见。再见。
let white men rule. Chilling stuff Dominic and what is to come is going to be even more chilling. Members of the rest of history club can hear that right away of course the battle for the future of the South and the fate of the
汤姆，我必须说，当我回顾我们在《历史的其余部分》中所做的一切的广度和深度时，它开始看起来有点像亚历山大图书馆，不是吗？是的，当然，亚历山大图书馆的问题在于它已经消失了。所以无论是被罗马人、基督人、穆斯林还是熵所摧毁，谁能说得清呢？但这是一种我们不希望在《历史的其余部分》图书馆身上看到的命运。因此，我们建立了一个巨大且极其令人印象深刻的数字纪念碑来存放我们所有的剧集。我们确实做到了。而且它当然是《历史的其余部分》的官方网站。我不知道你怎么想，汤姆，但当我看到那个网站时，我不认为我生命中有什么东西比这更让我感到快乐。
first incarnation of the Ku Klux Klan and what you can also hear if you are a member of the rest of the history club of the next two episodes after those two so episodes three and four which take the story into the 20th century. So to join them, if you're not a member, you know what you've got to do. Restishistory.com and sign up there. Thank you, Dominic. Thank you everyone for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
好吧，多米尼克，你知道我对此感到非常兴奋。特别是关于精选集。它以主题组织了系列和剧集。所以有古代史、征服者和探险家等等。我最喜欢的是英国历史，它按时间顺序从巨石阵一直讲到利兹·特拉斯的倒台。但我知道你喜欢精选集，但对我来说，真正的亮点，皇冠上的明珠，莫过于《历史的其余部分》档案。它是我们制作过的每一集的完整官方目录。它非常先进。它是由我们敬爱的阿塞尔斯坦人之一马特·波维在人工智能的帮助下构建的。
Tom, I have to say, when I look at the sheer sweep and scobere everything we've done on the Rest is History, it starts to look a little bit like the Library of Alexandria, doesn't it? Yeah, and of course, the problem with the Library of Alexandria was that it's gone. So whether it was destroyed by the Romans or the Christians or the Muslims or by entropy, who can say, But that is a fate that we do not want to see visited on The Rest Is History Library. And so we have built an enormous and exceedingly impressive digital monument to house all our episodes in. We have. And it is, of course, the official The Rest is History website. And I don't know about you, Tom, but when I look at that website, I don't think anything in my life has ever given me greater pleasure.
所以人工智能，不仅仅是邪恶的，它也做善事。这种高科技允许你按时代、人物、事件或嘉宾进行搜索。所以如果你想找出，例如，我们每次提到亨利八世或克伦威尔等等的时间，搜索功能会直接带你到那里。是的，这是一个很棒的东西，但它不是我们网站上唯一的东西。如果你是书迷，有一个特别的书籍部分。还有关于我们现场活动的所有详细信息，包括在汉普顿宫举行的非常令人兴奋的《历史的其余部分》节。
Well, you'll know, Dominic, I have been so excited about this. this, and particularly about the curated collections. So this features series and episodes organized by theme. So there's ancient history or conquistadors and explorers and so on. And my favourite one is the history of Britain, which goes all the way from Stonehenge up to the fall of Liz Truss in chronological order. But so I know you love the curated collections, but for me the real highlight, the jewel in the crown, no less, is the rest is history archive. So it is the complete official catalogue of every single episode that we have ever done. And it is so unbelievably high tech. It's been built by one of our beloved Athelstands, Matt Povey,
当然，还有一个地方可以让你购买我们独家的《历史的其余部分》周边商品。如果你是历史俱乐部其余部分的成员，那么你可以登录我们的独家会员区，在那里你可以找到你所有的账户详细信息、会员独家周边，以及最令人兴奋的会员专享迷你剧视频。现在，我想这里有一些正在看这个的人还不是会员。疯狂。这太疯狂了。
with the help of AI. So AI, not just since Sinister, it does good as well. And this high tech allows you to search by era or by person or by event or by guest. So if you wanted to find out, out, for instance, every time that we've mentioned, I don't know, Henry VIII or Cromwell or whatever, then the search function will take you straight there. Yeah, it's a brilliant thing, but it's not the only thing that we have on the website. There is a special book section if you're a book lover. There's all the details about our live events, including the very exciting Rest Is History Festival at Hampton Court.
所以对你们来说好消息是，网站也有自己的会员注册页面。所以你可以去网站，探索所有巨大的亮点，然后你可以去注册页面注册，成为会员，然后去会员独家区，然后买一些周边来庆祝。太棒了。在我们作为这个播客广告商的整个职业生涯中，我们一直在说没有比现在更好的注册时间了。但在这种情况下，这是字面上的真实。从来没有比现在更好的时间了。所以前往therestisistory.com。看看我们的新网站，然后去做你该做的事，注册。这很棒。我是真诚地、真实地、确切地这样认为的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
And of course, there is a place where you can buy yourself our exclusive Rest is History merch. And if you are a member of the rest of history club, then you can log into our exclusive members area where you can find all of your account details, your members exclusive merch, and most excitingly, the videos of our members-only mini-series. Now, I guess there are people here who are watching this who are not yet members. Madness. It is madness.
So the good news for you is the website also has its very own membership sign-up page. So you can go to the website, you can explore all the tremendous highlights, and then you can go to the sign up page and sign up, become a member, and then go to the member's exclusive area and then buy yourself some merch to celebrate. Brilliant. The whole way through our career as advertisers on this podcast, we have been saying there's never been a better time to sign up. But on this occasion, it is literally true. There never has been a better time. So head to the rest is history.com. Check out our new website and then do it. what you've got to do, sign up. It's great. And I genuinely, truly, authentically mean that. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.